ثمانيه اشخاص من اسره طالب
من اخوه الامير عبد الوهاب وابناء عمومته
حين راوا عبد الوهاب بن عامر قتيلا عفو
الحياه فقتلوا عن بكره ابيه الامير سليم
ينتصر في معركه وانا دائما اقول الاتراك
هدف في خطاب لها ارسلها الى الى احد اعيان
الحجاز فيقول اما الباشا
وبلهجته الدارجه فلا نرى الخط له وجه يعني
لا نرى الرساله
فان كان مراده
العافيه
منطقه شمال
يحدث ما يقلب المعادله
[موسيقى]
اهلا هذا فنجان من 8 وانا عبد الرحمن ابو
مالح وحده من الاشياء اللي نشتغل عليها في
ثمانيه اييي شرح السياقات التاريخيه
للبلدان العربيه شرحنا في عدد من الحلقات
عن تاريخ السعوديه الجزيره العربيه
والتاريخ السياسي لدول الخليج العربيه
[موسيقى]
من الاماكن اللي تهمني جدا هي الدخول في
شرح السياقات التاريخيه بشكل اعمق للمناطق
السعوديه لانها غزيره ومثيره ومتريه
واحيانا يعني لما تسوي شوي تشريح تفاصيل
جديده ومهمه
بعد ان شرحنا نجد في اكثر من حلقه ودي
ننتقل الى منطقه اخرى المنطقه اللي انتمي
اليها وولدت فيها منطقه عسير ما هو تاريخ
منطقه عسير قبل الدوله السعوديه الاولى من
كان يحكمها لما مذهبها وما هي مكونات
المجتمع انا ذلك كيف كان المشهد الثقافي
العلمي خلال 300 عام الماضي لماذا منطقه
عسير حضرت فيها القريه اكثر من القبيله
كيف تعاملت مع الغزوات والمعارك العثمانيه
على المنطقه كيف
تشكلت الجيوش للدفاع عن عسير وكيف انضمت
تحت كان في الدوله السعوديه الاولى بعد
سقوط الدوله السعوديه الاولى كيف تاثرت
وكيف تعاملت مع استمرار الهجوم الاثماني
الهجمات العثمانيه اللي استمرت في اكثر من
100 عام من
الاستيلاء والتحرير وكيف كانت علاقه عسير
مع جيرانها حيث انه عسير كانت البوابه
للدوله السعوديه الاولى والثالثه في ادخال
الحجاز ضمن السعوديه ما دور رجالات عسير
وطبيعه العلاقه مع امرائها وائمه الدوله
السعوديه والملك عبد العزيز في جهود توحيد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حلقه غزيره مع
ضيف غزير المعلومات الدقيقه التاريخ واسع
المعرفه الدكتور علي القطب استاذ مشارك في
التاريخ الحديث في جامعه الملك خالد
قبل ان نبدا
عندنا 22
دوله عربيه ودي اشرح كل دوله
مشاركوني اسماء من بلدانكم يساعدوني على
شرح السياقات التاريخيه الاجتماعيه
لهذه الدول ودي اعرف اكثر الكل يحتاجه
يعرف اكثر شاركوني هذه الاسماء على بريد
البرنامج
دوت كوم
لنبدا
مع
الزلفه
والله احنا كلنا نتناقشه انا
طبعا انا تربطني بحلاقه
في ما يخص خاصه
لكن موف في في مسائل كثيره لانه انطلق من
اين كان يشرد
او يقارب الموضوعات التاريخيه
كان ينطلق من خلال المنطلقات قبليه
او كانت القبيله حاضره في ذهني
وانا اؤكد يعني منك كباحث وتخصص في هذه
المنطقه
وفي مناطق جنوب العربيه
تاريخ بشري عادي تاريخ بشري تتفاعل فيها
اشياء كثيره جدا ليست القبيله هي اللي هي
الفاعل الرئيسي والابرز النهائي في
المساله
حتى الاماره او الامارات السياسيه
والسلطات السياسيه بتعاقبت لم تنتقل لم
تكن تنطلق من منطلقات قبل
لا هناك هناك قراءه مغلوطه بتاريخ الميلاد
في الان موجود في المنطقه مؤثرات كثيره من
اهم المؤثرات الموجوده في فينا المؤثر
مثلا القبلي او العشائري
مشكله تاريخ تاريخ المنطقه بشكل عام تاريخ
منطقه عسيرنا ياخذ من خلال ابعد اما بعد
قبلي او بعد عائلي
وهذا بالنسبه
لي انا كباحث غير دقيق
واظنه مجازي الحقيقي
المجتمع كان كان متاثرا بدرجه كبيره او
كان المحور لدى الفرج في منطقه عسير هو
قريب اكثر من قبيله والقريه مكونه من ايش
من قبيله في الاصل ليس بالضروره
مجموعه عوائل فيها كثير من الناس
ملائكه
كثير والمجتمعات العربيه فيها ايضا فئات
مهمشه اوهامشيئه لكنه في نهايه المطاف
مجتمع معجون
لم يكن لم يكن قبليا بالدرجه التي تتصورها
وتعامل معها على انها مثلا خاصه المكونات
القبليه الضخمه في المنطقه التعامل معها
على انها كتله صلبه واحده
غير دقيق وغير صحيح لان هذه الكتله الضخمه
جدا تتمدد على منطقه جغرافيه شاسعه ما بين
ما بين وجود شرقيه الى جبال عاليه جدا
اللي هي جبال السروات او المتن السعودي
الى
السهول او الاغوار التهاميه وبالتالي كانت
ثقافتهم مختلفه تماما عن بعضهم البعض
وكانوا متميزين عن بعضهم البعض الى درجه
انه مغتربين فيها اشياء كثيره حتى في
اللهجه حتى في الازياء حتى في الذاكره في
الذاكره الشعبيه حتى في امور كثيره
التعامل مع التاريخ من خلال انه هذه
المكونات القبليه كانت كتله واحده غير
دقيقه
همم صحيح ابدا
نحط بعض الاساسيات اعطيني حدود الجغرافيه
اولا في في نقطه مهمه جدا وعصير لها
دلالات ليس الدلاله واحده
الدلاله الجغرافيه
زهره
هذه الدلاله الجغرافيه
وهي دلاله ليس الثابته بطبيعه الحال ليس
الثابته لكن هذا ما استقر في الاذهب
هناك دلاله قبليه وهي تعني مكون قبلي ضخم
موجود في عمق اقليم عشيره او في عمق منطقه
عسيريه يضم حوالي تقريبا
اربع قبائل او اربع فروع قبليه كبار في
السره
وحوالي تقريبا ربما تكون اكثر من 15 فرعا
من الفروع القبليه في تهامه تمتد من
مدينه او محافظه الدرب حتى تقريبا قنفذه
او شمال المنطقه
هذه الدلاله هذه او هذا المكون القبلي هذا
المكون القبلي
هو هو ودلاله المسمى دلاله عسير القبليه
هي جاءت من خلال هذا المكون القبلي في
العشاء
والدليل على ذلك
ابن الحايك الحمداني في صفحه جزيره العرب
حين ذكر او حين مر بمنطقه عسير
ذكر عسير بدلالتها القبليه ولم يذكرها
بدلالتها الجغرافيه
كانها قبيله يحدها من شاميها من الشمال
موجوده
و ثم ذكر اوديتها وذكر مواطنها وديارها
والتي لازالت حتى اللحظه موجوده وهذا في
القرن الرابع الهجري
يعني قبل الف سنه
وذكر حتى مدينه ابها
ذكرى
فالدلال القبليه هي هي الجذر
الى المسمى عسير بدلاله الجغرافيه
في وتفصيل ذلك انه في مع العصور الحديثه
وحين قامت
العديد من السلطات السياسيه المتعاقبه
كان اكثر او كل او جميع امراء عسير كانوا
من هذه القبيله هذا المكون قبل سواء امراء
للمتحمي او امراء
هم بسبب هذا الانتماء القبلي بسبب هذا
الحضور نعم تعمم الاسم ليصبح دلاله على
على على هذه البقعه الجغرافيه لذلك سبب في
ذلك ايضا يعود
الى الى ما ورد في التقارير الاجنبيه في
وفي الوثائق العثمانيه حين كانوا يتحدثون
على المقاومه الظاهريه التي كانت موجوده
كانوا يذكرون
عشيره هكذا واضح انهم كانوا يقصدون
الدلاله الجغرافيه
وعمق هذه القبيله
والامراء الذين ناضلوا وكافحوا للزوج
وشهري شهراني والقحطاني
كانت موجوده وقتها
مثلا
ذكر وقال اني مرتب قبيله هل كان يقصد هذه
القبائل كلها ولا هي بس كانت في وقت
يقصد عسير القبيله تحديدا بدلالتها
القبليه
وذكر القبائل الاخرى الكريمه اللي كانت
موجوده مثل القبائل رجال الحجر مثل
القبائل جنب سعد العشيره وجوده في سراه
عبيده مثل القبائل رفيده مثل القبائل
شهران العريضه مثل هذه المكونات القبليه
الضخمه
وهو هي قديمه ولذلك وليس غريبا بالنسبه
للشيخ حمد الجيش حين يتحدث عن المساله
الانساب طبعا المنظمين ليس قطعيا باي حال
من الاحوال حين يتحدث عن عن مساله الانساب
وكذا فيقول بما بما مضمونه انه انه اكثر
القبائل العربيه التي بقيتها حفظت على
مسمياتها القديمه هي القبائل الواقعه في
جنوب مكه
محافظه على الاسماء القديمه يعني مثلا على
سبيل المثال حين نقول شهران العريس
وهو جاهلي يقول اتوننا بشهران العريضه
كلها واكل بها في مثل بكر
فهذا هذه القبائل بقيت بمسمياتها بقيت
طبعا هذا لا يعني هناك الكثير من ربما من
العشائر والافخاذ والبطون قد دخلت
والتحمت في بعضها البعض ان يتذكر يا اخي
عبد الرحمن انه انه بالنسبه للنشر او
الرابطه الدمويه هي رابطه متخيله
متخيله ليست
ليست لا يظن انها ان كل ابناء هذه القبيله
ينتسبون الى جده واحد هذا وهم هذا هذا غير
صحيح والاختلاط في الانساب قديم جدا منذ
منذ الجاهليه
لكن القبيله دائما القبيله وهذا طبيعه
العرب انهم يحاولون ان
يشددون او يحاولون ان يعززون
لحمتهم من خلال ايجاد او سرديه سرديه
تتعلق برابطه دمويه معينه ماء او قصه
معينه وهكذا
والا الخلاف بين النشابه الجاهليه
وهو متوفي تقريبا في سنه 2004
يختلفون في كثير من الانساب
القبائل العربيه حتى النوعين عدده ودخلوا
في الفروع والبطون والعشائر يعددونها
فانهم قد يذكرون انه هذه العشيره يقال في
نسبها ويقال هكذا وسبب ذلك كما بسطها ابن
خلدون في مقدمه يتعلق
بوجود ظروف اجتماعيه وتاريخيه هو اقتصاديه
حافه هي التي تجعل العشائر تنضوي الى
بعضها البعض وتلتحم في بعضها البعض ويخرج
هذا المكون القبلي يخرج هذا المكون القبلي
وبشرديه خاصه تغذي تغذي لحمته ودائما تكون
عن طريق الدم والا فهي رابطه بلا شك وتخيل
طيب همم اذا فهمت من كلامك اللي قبل شوي
في ناس كثير
بافهم انك همم اسم عسير دلاله للقبيله همم
الجغرافيه اللي عزا التسميه لها الدكتور
محمد زلفه انها طبيعتها للتضاريس
وهذا هذا وارد وارد عند العرب ان تنتسب
منطقه او مكانه الى قبيله حين نقول جبل
شمر
فهو نسبه الى هذه القبيله حين نقول وادي
الدواسر
نسبه الى هذه الى قبيله الدواسر
حين نقول منطقه عسير
لهذه القضيه
وعلته كما ذكرته لك هي المقاومه الضاره
التي التي خرجت من هذه من هذه من هذا
المكور القبلي والامراء الذين تعاوروا على
حكم المنطقه من هذا المكون القبلي
والقضاه والوزراء والكثير من الاولى كثير
من المؤثرين كانوا دائما يخرجون من هذا
المكون القبلي والسبب في ذلك انا في رايي
انه لماذا هي كانت
في رايي
هو لا يتعلق مثلا في كل القبائل العربيه
لديها النخوه والشجاعه والبطوله والفروسيه
والى اخره لكن انا في تقديري وفي تحليلي
مرد ذلك الى الى التصاقها الكبير جدا
بالارض
وظروفها الاقتصاديه الجيده هي تعيش في في
او تتمدد على على اكثر المناطق او الاماكن
او المواضع خصوبه
وبالتالي وبالتالي كان من الواجب ومن
المتعلم
عن هذه الارض لم يكن لديها خيار خيار اخر
لم يكن لديه لم يكن لدى المقاتل او
المدافع عن منطقه في منطقه عسير الا ان
يدافع عن ارضيه وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعل
انه انه تكون هناك مثلا بؤره جغرافيه
معينه اكثر دفاعا عن البؤره اخرى هو بسبب
اغتصاب في الارض فالناس كانوا في في تلك
المنطقه ااه
ملتصقين جدا في الارض ولا شك انه المنطقه
ده المجتمع بشكل عام بكل مكوناته دورا
كبيرا جدا في مقاومه
و و الاثباتات على ذلك موجوده يعني وطائفه
بس بدي
التسميه ليش الخلاف
في تسميه
شمر
والاماكن الثانيه بينما اسير في هذه
الخلاف ما بين ان اسير
نسبهون بين الدلالات الدلالات الدلال
القبليه والدلاله الجغرافيه لم يحاول
وفعلا هناك لبس في المساله هناك منطقه
تسمى عسير وهناك مكون من قبل يسمى عسير
هناك كلبش لكن حين ننظر الى التاريخ ونذهب
الى الجذور التاريخيه سننظر انها البدايه
كانت من خلال الدلاله القبليه
ثم اتجهت الى ان اخذت بعدا جغرافيا همم
شاسعا واسع وعلى فكره هذا هذه المساله
ذكرها فؤاد حمزه في في كتابه في بلاد عسير
وحررها بدقه شديده جدا
وكان عنده نظر في هذه المساله
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
طيب فيها نقطه
معرفيه حدثت في عسير
وانه ابناء عسير
تخلوا عن كل ما يتعلق بتاريخهم
قبل مطلع القرن الثامن عشر وتغافل تماما
عن تدوين الفتره السابقه
وهو سحب اصلا سحب المفهوم من من
نظيره
صاحب ما يسميه القطيع
هو هو قد ينقطع او يمر بقطعه انا في رايي
في ما يخص تاريخ منطقه عسير
بانه دخول منطقه عشير في كندا الدوله
السعوديه الاولى
كان قطيعه مع ما قبلها
وكان حدثا تاريخيا
جوهريا بالنسبه لمنطقه عسير وهو بلا شك
بلا شك انه هو العامل الابرز في في في
بعثه تاريخيه كان تاريخ هناك بعض المناطق
في الجزيره العربيه
فرديتها التاريخيه غير مكتمله صورتها
التاريخيه غير مكتمله مثل منطقه
ليست كامله الصوره
نحن لا نستطيع ان نعرف
بدقه شديده جدا من القضاه من الامراء من
الوزراء الذين كانوا موجودين في القناه
التاسعه الهجريه مثلا
مثل على سمير المثال منطقه الحجاز تاريخ
معلوم مشهور ايضا تاريخ المخالفه
السليماني تاريخها معلوم مشهور وهناك
مدونات تاريخيه لكن منطقه نجد عسير الى حد
ما هناك ضبابيه كبيره جدا في صوره الواقع
التاريخي لكل مجالاته السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والثقافيه والفكريه والدينيه
امور
الشباب
هناك بعض الكوارث والاحداث التاريخيه التي
مثلا انقضت على بعض بعض المخطوطات
والوسائل
هناك ايضا بالنسبه
لمنطقه عسير تحديث
في انضمامها للدوله السعوديه الاولى
من اوتاد الدوله السعوديه الاولى في جنوب
افريقيا الجزيره العربيه
وقدم امراءها من المتحمي يعني تضحيات
كبيره جدا وبطوليه
وغيرهم طبعا من القاده والفرسان
ااا
هذه المنطقه ايضا ابدت حماسه كبيره في
تقبل دعوه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب تحديث
تعرف دعوه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب كانت
مرحله
الحركه التاريخيه السعوديه
في منطقه عسير ابده حماشه كبيره جدا لتقبل
الدعوه لم يوجد ولا يعني كل المناطق كان
هناك فيها معارضه في منطقه نجد او في
منطقه الحجاز او حتى في منطقه الخلافه
سليمان يعني حتى في اليمن او غيرها من
المناطق او حتى في الاحشاء الا من منطقه
عسير لم يثبت او لم يرد ان هناك من عارض
دعوه الشيخ محمد عبد الوهاب من الناحيه
الدينيه مع العلم انه
يتكلم بشكل ثاني هنتكلم عن العلماء الذين
كانوا موجودين
العلماء كبار العلماء
بدرجه كبيره
في الدوله السعوديه الاولى لا يجب النظر
اليه
ما يجب النظر اعتبار انه
مازن لا يستحق ان يدور لا يستحق ان يكون
جزء من الذاكره
ناس تنظر الى النظام
في رايي ان هناك كان هناك في مجتمع منطقه
عسير حاله من حاله التطهر
من حدثت هناك بعض المجتمعات تحدث ربما
تكون مفاتيح
ثم يصيبها نوع من التطهر فتعود
تتبنى خطابا او نسقا فكريا معين
وبحيث انه هذا النشاط يكون هو
الذاكره الوحيد
[موسيقى]
نضعها بين ثنائيه
او اسلام وجاهليه وهذا من هذا من هذا من
هذا السياق الحاد جدا لكنه كان ينظر الى
هذه
ينظر الى هذه
المنطقه ااه فض طبعا فضلا عن قله التدوين
وفضلنا عنا عن عن عن الحوادث التي مرت بها
منطقه عسير لكن كان ينظر الا يجب ان تسجل
او تدور نظرتهم لانفسهم
موجوده ايضا حتى لو تلاحظ في في في
عند ابن بشر مثلا
يكتب يكتب في ثوابه
يسميه ما قبل دعوه الشيخ محمد عبد الوهاب
ثم لا يقيم لها وزنها وتلاحظ في في مدونات
او في مدوناته لا يحفل كثيرا
وانما يحفل في تاريخه من بعد من بعد همم
1177 50 الاتفاق الذي عقده الامام محمد بن
سعود مع الشيخ محمد عبد الوهاب قبل هذا
التاريخ لا يحفل كثيرا ويسميه ثوابت اي
انها اشبه ما تكون بالماء طبعا قدم لنا
خدمه جليله جدا في معرفه الواقع التاريخ
حين تنظر مثلا الى الى ظل الممدود
السعوديه
كتب كتابه التاريخي يتحدث فيه عن
انضمام عسيري لكن في الدوله السعوديه
الاولى 10 من عمره ربما ربما عاش اكثر من
ثلاثي عمره
للدوله السعوديه الاولى ومع ذلك لم يكتب
عنها
عن منطقه عسير
وسرديه كيف انضمت الى الدوله السعوديه
الاولى
خمس سنوات
فحين نقول ان هناك قطيعه معرفه هذا يحدث
تحدث عند كثير من من الشعوب والمجتمعات
وهي نظريه سائره يعني سياره في العالم وفي
حقل الكتابه التاريخيه
[موسيقى]
هل ما كان في شيء
يا اخي عبد الرحمن احنا احنا طبعا هناك
مقاربات مختلفه في حقيقه الواقع التاريخ
الذي كان موجود قبل قبل
في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
هناك مقاربه تقول ان هناك فتاه قبليه
يعني
يشتغل بها او يتبناها العديد من المؤرخين
الذين يعتبرون يعني معتبرين
رحمه الله
هناك مقاربه اخرى مثلا
تقول انه انه منطقه عسير كانت تابعه
للائمه سيدييه في اليمن
على مدينه ابها بالجبال الغربيه في في
مدينه ابها
بعمق تهامه
ان هناك تكوين سياسي صغير كان اخر امراءه
الامير محمد بن احمد من بلده
امتداد
هذا الامير
هذا الامير هو ال بحسب المصادر انه ربما
يكون معارضا
[موسيقى]
لانضمام عسيري الى كان في الدوله السعوديه
الاولى وقاتل في حين انه جزء كبير من
المجتمع في منطقه عسير كان مؤيد
اصول والدوله الدوله
طبيعه حكم
عسير ما قبل الدوله السعوديه
اليمن
خلينا نحرر مفهوم اليمن اول شيء
كلما كان كل ما كان جنوب الكعبه
ومن اجل ذلك يقال الركن اليماني لانه
جنوبيه الكعبه
تمام
الجغرافيين الذين او عفوا غير المدققين
الذين اخذوا هذا الموضوع اعتباطا او اخذوه
ببناء على هذه الدلاله الجهويه
يضعون منطقه عسير
وشطرا كبيره من منطقه نجد وعمر
جزء من منطقه الاحساء يضعونها داخل في
اليمن
بناء على هذه الجهه لانه اي شيء او اي
منطقه جنوبيه الكعبه
الجغرافيه او الجغرافيين والبلدانين
المدققين الذين يحاولون قدر الامكان
يعني ينظرون الى المسمى بدلالاته
الجغرافيه
طلحه الملك
هي الحد الفاصل بين ولايه مكه ولايه اليمن
قرر ذلك المسعودي في القرن الرابع الهجري
يقرر ان اطول طلحه
الملكه هذه شجره كبيره موجوده في ضاحيه من
ضواحي مدينه طهران جنوب
يعني يعني قريبه من
المنفذ اليمني
لك ان تتخيل
ومتى قال هذا الكلام
300 تقريبا 46
قرر ذلك ايضا قرب ذلك البكري في معجم
مستعجل
وذكر انه حد عمل مكه
ثم ذكر ذلك ابن فضل الله العمري في مسالك
الابصار
القرن الثامن الهجري
فكل هذه النصوص وذكر ذلك حتى ايضا صاحب
مراصد الاطلاع وهو في الثامن الهجريه
في نفس الحدود الموجوده حاليا وهذا على
فكره
وانا كنت تابع في في ابحث في بعض المصادر
التاريخيه وحتى في مساله الحدود السعوديه
اليمنيه لم اجد هذه النصوص مستحضره
لم اجد هذه النصوص وهذا طبيعي لقدم تلك
الفتره لكن الان النصوص طافح بهذه المساله
قطعيه ولايه مكه تنتهي عند طلحه طلحه
الملك
هو ثم يبتدا
جنوبا اقليم اليمن جغرافيا
فهذه المساله تقريبا
محسومه ما يخص بالنسبه
الامام الشوكاني رحمه الله وهو عالم من
علماء القناه الثالثه عشر
ومن العيار الثقيل وهو قاضي القضاه في
زمنه وكان يكتب خطاباته ويحررها على لسان
الامام المنصوره بالله الامام المنصور
الزيدي في في صنعاء
فهناك رساله من الامام المنصوره الى
شريف غالب في سنه 1216 هجري 1801
يتحدث فيه عن وصوله
او قدوم
او ظهور دعوه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب
فيقول بالنص بالحرف
يقول وجمل التي تسلطا
يعني اصول الدعوه وجمله تسلطه على عوام من
اغتام
لا يعرفون رسوم الاسلام
[موسيقى]
وهم اهل الشام
الواقعه اراضيهم ما بين صعده والطائف
من هو يقصدها للشاب يقصد منطقه عسير
وهم ثم يعقب وهم ليسوا على تحت ولايتنا
ولا يدينون بمذهبين
[موسيقى]
هذا الامام الشوكاني يقول ذلك على لسان
الامام المنصور
وفي رسالته للشريفه
وقلب البحث يعني
حكم الاشراف مركز منطقه
في فترات ربما وصل بعض نفوذهم السياسي
مكه وصل الى بيشه وصل الى شمال
لكن انا بالنسبه لي انا اقارب المساله
وانظر الى الموضوع بان هناك كان هناك
تكوين السياسي يحفظه بمدينه ابها
وبالمنطقه الحسبه الواقعه في الغربيه
ولاجل ذلك همم
كان عندها هو اخر امير وهذا هو السبب الذي
يفسر لاحقا اصلا ااا
وصول الامير شهيد ان شاء الله الى حكم
المنطقه في سنه 1238
1823 ميلادي ما يخص
الامراء المتحمي كان لهم طبعا ثقل كبير
جدا اجتماعيه وهذا هو السبب الذي جعلهم
يحشمون المساله في مساله انضمام عسيري الى
كان في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
الامير محمد بن عامر الامير عبد الوهاب بن
عامر بحسب نصوص البهكري
طيب طيب
بس قبل برضه حتى اسير عشان اقفل الملف
اليمن بدي اعرف منك يعني فتحت الملف فلما
نقول ان اليمن هم اصل العرب
وانا احاول اقارب الواقع التاريخي او او
قادر على انك تحسب كل الامور
اظنها حدثت في اشياء
روايات متكافره متضافره
حول العديد من المكونات القبليه العربيه
منذ الجاهليه وحتى اللحظه
من المعروف انه منطقه
اليمن الجغرافيا
وحتى مناطق جنوب غرب الجزيره العربيه كانت
اشبه ما يكون بالخزان البشري الذي
يفيض على على مناطق شمال الجزيره
حين تنظر الى كتب النسب مثلا ستجد انه
كثير من هذه المكونات القبليه او الروايات
تتظافر على انه كثير من مكونات القبليه
الموجوده في وسط الجزيره العربيه او في
غربها او في شمالها او في شرقيها او حتى
في خارجها
ينسبونها الى القبائل القحطانيه
الى القبائل القحطانيه خذ على سبيل المثال
قبيلهم التي كانت في مكه
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام في المدينه
المنوره
اخذ على سبيل المثال قبيل الطيب يقال انه
منازلهم القديمه كانت في وادي الطريق
في الكتابات الكتابات النشبه يرون انها
قحطانيه يمنيه فمن هذا من هذه المقولات
المتظافره المتكافره تنشا مقوله واصل
العرب من اليمن حتى في العصر الحديث حين
انظر الى كثير من القبائل الموجوده حاليا
هناك فرديات كثيره جدا ومرويات تفيد
بالقحطانيتها مثلا او انها قدمت من الجنوب
غرب الجزيره العربيه ام الجنوب الجزيره
العربيه خذ على سبيل المثال بني مره بني
هاجر العجمان
حتى قبيله عايد في بعض الاقوال حتى قبيله
بني زيد القضائيه في بعض الاقوال
وقبيله او فرع العباده من شمر
وكثير من القبائل كثير يعني
من المرويات التي تقول بقحطانيه هذه
القبائل وبالتالي همم
المقوله كانها كانها
كانها حاله استقراء لهذه المرويات او
كانها لفظه استقرائيه لهذه الكثره الكافره
من المروريه
اذاعه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
النادي النادي الهلال السعودي وهذا
السعودي
استقبال في الرياض كان خيالي
في كره القدم
واحطم الرقم السعودي والرقم العربي في هذا
المسابقه
الى اعماق الشعبي
فريقنا السعوديه لالعاب القوى يدخلوا
منافساتها في مجموعه من اللاعبين اللي انا
فعلا كنت افوز عليهم واستطاعوا انهم
يتوجوا ميداليات في اولمبياد
[موسيقى]
في طريق حياتهم فجرت قنبله
اجتماعيه
كان يريد ان يتيح فرصه للدماء الجديده
مردومه
الى الان الى الان اثار اصابات موجوده
الان
[تصفيق]
النتيجه على طول يعني كان فيها انتظار
لانها تظهر النتيجه في الساعه في وقتها
كنا يعني في حير
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اثناء القاء القصيده كان الصمت يا عم
واخترت انا اكون اا ان اظهر كما انا انت
مفصوله عشان انت طلعتي بالتلفزيون
[موسيقى]
يعني
خلونا نعيش حياتي
[موسيقى]
في الحكم
بتكلم عن الانجليزي
طبيعه الحب ليس بالضروره
هناك هناك بطن
مدرج ضمن او ضمن الفل البطون في في اماره
الناجح المنتهي الى قبيله بني مغيض يطلق
عليهم
تمييزا او
كدلالهم الذين يسكنون في في في في وسط
بلده الشجاع وهي منطقه بسيطه
الذين تامروا الذين وصلوا الى شده الاماره
في عسير هم هؤلاء الامراء الذين هم من فرع
ال يزيد القهوه
في المنطقه او في تاريخ المنطقه
امم
الاقرار بهذا بهذا البطن بان هذا الاسم
هذا هو اسمه لكن مساله
انتشابهم الى يزيد بن معاويه بن ابي سفيان
هذا شان اخر احتاج الى يحتاج الى راي
يحتاج الى راي ويحتاج الى دراسه بس انت
تذكر انه برضه انه هذا وارد طبعا هناك
اشارات هناك اشارات لكن ما هو المهم ما هو
المهم في المساله
ان التكوين او التكوين السياسي في منطقه
عسير
بعد بعد انحسار نفوذ الدوله السعوديه
الاولى منطقه عسير وبعد سقوط اماره
المتحده وظهور الامير سعيد ومسلط انه كان
هذا الحضور هو
ليس بسبب النشب
مطلق ولم ينظر الناس الى هذه ولم يكرش
اصلا هؤلاء الامراء هذا النشاط وانما كان
هذا الظهور بسبب تمثلهم للابعاد الثقافيه
والاجتماعيه كان هناك نوع من
طبعا لا شك انه شخصياتهم كانت شخصيات
بطوليه
يعني هم كانوا الناس ينظرون اليهم بانهم
ربما يكون هؤلاء الافراد او هؤلاء الامراء
هم الذين سيخلصون المنطقه من حملات محمد
علي باشا
بهذه الصوره
طيب الحين كان همم
اليزيدين كان محمد احمد همم احمد بن احمد
اليزيدي اميرا لياسير بحسب ال ال المقاربه
التي انا اقول بها او اتبناه
وبانه هذا طبعا المعلومات عنه صحيحه جدا
للغايه وقليله جدا وهو وهو مذكور في بعض
الروايات الشفهيه وفي بعض الاشعار ومذكور
ايضا في ولا زال يعني له معك الموجود في
بلده همم
واشير له يعني في بعض الدراسات او المراجع
التاريخيه لكن كان كان همم كانت اماراته
صغيره ما هي المشكله يعني يعرج على مسلمه
مهمه جدا
وهذه لازم ننتهي منها
هي مشكله مصادر تاريخ المنطقه
نحن نحن
في مازق كبير بسبب
وجود جمله من المصادر التاريخيه
التي اساءت في تاريخ المنطقه ولم تختب
مصادر تاريخيه
مثل الكتاب بتاع الشاعر
مثل الكتاب مذكرات سليمان شفيق باشا
على سبيل المثال الكتاب تاريخ عسير
كلها هذه المصادر او المراجع يا اخ عبد
الرحمن منحوله موضوعه مزوره
وجود هذه الشخصيات لكنها لا يثبت انهم
الافوها
حتى وان طوت حتى وين انطوت هذه معلومات
هذه المصادر حتى وانطوت معلومات هذه
المصادر على معلومات صحيحه لكن الكتاب
يبقى مزورا لا يستطيع لا احد يستطيع ان
يوثق منه او يعول عليه لانه كتابه مزور
حين يقول مثلا انه كتاب مؤلف في سنه 1300
مثلا و 64 او 63 وهو لم يكن كذلك لم يؤلف
في هذا التاريخ من لم يكتب مثلا همم حاله
مثلا بتاع الشامل ينسب الى شعيب بن عبد
الحميد الدوسري لم يغلف شويه بهذا لا يوجد
اثبات لا توجد افرازات او نسخ من هذا
المخطوط تثبت ان شعيب بن عبد الحميد
الدوسري الف هذا الكتاب
ممكن تثبت ان واحد كتب كتاب لان الكتاب
نفسه
كيف
ممكن تنفي حين مثلا ناتي على عنوان المجد
بشر مخطوطاتها موجوده في كل مكان
المخطوطات القديمه هذا الكتاب خرج لم يخرج
الا بعد عام 1407 والمؤلف توفي سنه 1365
طبعا انه ينسب الى مؤلف توفي سنه 1365
فبالتالي بصرف النظر عن اخراج
مثل هذه المصادر غير دقيقه لا يمكن
التعويل عليها لانها مزوره لانها موضوع
وهذا موجود ترى عند علماء الحديث هذا
المنهج النقدي
[موسيقى]
على لسان النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام يعني
حتى المعلومات اللي افترضنا انه هناك
معلومات مثلا صحيحه لا ينبغي التعويل عليه
لا يجب
لان الكتاب في اصله غير صحيح
غير صحيح مزور
لا يعرف من الفه
فينظر اليه بهذه المساله هذه المصادر
وكبيره وضخمه وحاربه
حاربه
في جنوب الجزيره العربيه في اليمن محاربه
حتى في ربما في عمان
وهذه المعلومات
ما يسمى بالاماره الي سيتي
وضعت السلسله كامله هائله جدا من
المعلومات التاريخيه المغلوط
رسائل
ال سعود
واين قراتها هذه قراتها في تاريخ عشيره
الاخ عبد الله اخي عبد الرحمن الباحث يجب
ان يتجرد الحقيقه التاريخيه يجب ان يتجرد
حين نقول ان هذا المصدر مغلوط
فهذا هو الحب هذا هو الذي يؤمن باشا
محمد بن سعود كان
تعامل مع المتحمي
اذا تبغى نتحدث عنها
لم تحكم عسكريه
بصرف النظر عن تلك المصادر
[موسيقى]
تكوين سياسي وترى في اشارات في اشارات
مثلا في بعض المخطوطات الحفظيه
تقول انه منطقه عسير قبل دعوه الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الوهاب قد خضعت لملك ابوك
يعني
في نوع من التكوين السياسي الصغير وربما
كان ملك او اماره متورثه
نقطه اخرى
حين انتصر الامير سعيد في ثورته عام 1238
على الاتراك العثمانيين يقول الشاعر
ولك التاويل يقول الشاعر يا مرحبا واهلا
بحكام الزمان
وولد اسلم راس كلهم مقدم ايش معنى مرحبا
واهلا بحكام الزمان
تسلسل في الامارات
فهناك اشارات
تؤشر على وجود تكوين سياسي نزل
الامير محمد بن احمد اليزيدي موجود الى
الان في بلده الشقق
هذا الامر
من مدينه ابها
الاماره الصغيره يبدو انها عارضت
الدوله السعوديه الاولى وعرضت انضمام
عسيري الى الدوله السعوديه الاولى وهذا
طبيعي اكثر اكثر
المناطق
عرضت الدوله السعوديه الاولى لانها كانت
فكره فكره وليده لم تتعود الجزيره العربيه
على حركه حركه مثل الحركه التاريخيه
السعوديه لم تتعود هذه حقيقه مئات السنين
وكانت منطقه الجزيره العربيه مناطق
الجزيره العربيه غير منتظمه في وحده
سياسيه واحد هذا طبيعي
استغرق توحيدها
وهذا يدل على ماذا يدل على انه فيه هناك
معارضه كبيره جدا
للدوله السعوديه الاولى لان والسبب في ذلك
نعود عودا على بنت بانه لم يكن يدور في
اذهان الناس وجود وحده سياسيه الدوله
الحركه التاريخيه السعوديه انا اعتبرها
حركه رائده وحركه مختلفه او حركه كانت همم
انا في رايي هي التي ادخلت الجزيره
العربيه في عصرها الحديث بلا شك
طبعا قبل انضمام عسيري لك انا في الدوله
السعوديه الاولى
وكما ذكرت لانه دعوه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الوهاب كانت
جزء او مرحله من مراحلها الحركه التاريخيه
السعوديه
فبدات بعض
الجهات في منطقه عسير تتمنى وتوالي
الامام عبد العزيز بن محمد الثاني
الثالثه عشر الهجري
التبني حدث قبل ذلك بحوالي خمس سنوات سنه
1195 هجري
على اول من ذكر ذلك هو المؤرخ الصنعاني
لطف الله جحافي في كتابه اللامع درر بحور
الحور العين في ايام الامام المنصور
واعلام دولته الميامي لانه بعض القبائل
الواقعه او بعض الجهات في في شمال شرق
منطقه عسير قد تبنت او اصبحت مواليه
للامام عبد العزيز بن محمد
على اثر ذلك تبدا
يتم التبني في داخل منطقه عسير بعد هذا
التاريخ بعد سنه 1195
ويبدا
بحسب ايضا هذا المؤرخ الصنعاني التكوين
القبلي الموجود في
تبدا بين بعض العشائر او بعض المكونات
القبليه او اشبه ما يكون بينناش مواليد
وناس معرضين
يبداون في صراع مع بعضهم البعض
الذي حكم المساله
هو وفاده الاميرين عبد الوهاب محمد بن
عامر بن عبد الوهاب بن عامر ابو نقطه حميد
اجتماعي كبير وثقيل اجتماعيا كانت علاقتهم
بمحمد بن احمد اليزيدي لم يكن لهم علاقه
بحسب المصادر لا يثبت ان الوجود هناك
علاقه ابدا ابدا بس كان يحكمون كانوا
ثقيلين في
اوساطير او في اوساط المجتمع خارج مدينه
ابها
بحسب العلامه البهكلي
طبعا لهم هجره او رحله رحله سنه 1213
ورحله اخرى سنه 1215 الرحله الاولى لطلب
العلم
والتقصي والمعرفه
الهجره الثانيه
فكانت الدقيقه مكان علم مكان علمو مكان
ايضا النفوذ خرجت على منطقه اصبحت خارجه
يعني خريطتها السياسيه خرجت من منطقه نجد
واصبحت مسيطره حتى على منطقه الخليج على
على منطقه الاحساء والقطيف في تلك الفتره
وكانت اصبح نفوذه السياسي همم
خريطه السياسيه واسعه جدا السمع والبصر في
الجزيره العربيه في ذلك الوقت فكان طبيعي
1798 ميلادي الرحله الثانيه كانت عام 1215
وبحسب ما يفهم من المصادر
لانها كانت جبرا
وربما كانت من هذا الامير الذي كان موجود
ارتحل الى الدرعيه ثم
بحسب روايه البهكلي والبهكلي حجه سبت لا
يسال عن مثله
وهو من اكابر العلماء في المخلف السليماني
ومؤرخ مدقدق
يقول ان الامام عبد العزيز حين وفد حين
وفد عليه اذان الرجلان راى فيهما مخائيل
الرئاسه
فعرض الاماره على محمد ابن عامر فرفضها
محمد بن عامر اما زهدا واما خوفا من تحمل
اعبائي
اماراتي اماره المنطقه
بالكامل وتصبح امير المنطقه
فرنسا
فعرضها على عبد الوهاب ابن عامر
ثم كلف القائد السعودي او القائد ربيع بن
زيد الدوسري احد وجهها في منطقه وادي
الدواس واحد القاده والفرسان المشهورين
شخص اخر ايضا قائد عسكري من اهل بيشه
يسمى جبران وتجهه ومعهم على راس هذا الجيش
الامير محمد بن عامر الامير عبد الوهاب بن
عامر
وتمكن هذا الجيش من السيطره عسير
وبسطه سيطرت
الجيش والنفوذ السعودي
هو وصلت وصلت الاخبار وصلت بدا التبني كما
قلت لك في سنه 1195
للدوله السعوديه الاولى
في اقصى شمال شرق عصير بدا في عام 1195
يعني لكن لم يكتمل
ضم عشيره بالكامل
ويطبق المجتمع على التبني تبني
الولاء للدوله السعوديه الاولى الا في سنه
من
حرجا من تحمل الاعباء او ربما جهن ويؤثر
عنهما انهما كان على جانب كبير من التقوى
فالحاصل انه الامير محمد بن عامر كانت
مهمته الاولى هو التثبيت وتوطييد نفوذ
الدوله السعوديه الاولى في منطقه عسير
ونجح في ذلك نجاح كبير
واصبح الطبق العاصمه لمنطقه عسير في ذلك
الزمان
وكان عنده طبعا هناك بعض القلاقل او
الاضطرابات سواء فيه تهامه او سواء في
شمال منطقه عسير انتهى منها بنجاح وبعد ان
اطبقه المنطقه او ضمه بشكل كامل راى هذا
الامير ان يرى سوفتا ويتجه به الى الدرعيه
كان ذلك في سنه 111780
اتجه الى الامام عبد العزيز محمد
فاكرمه الامام عبد العزيز واحسن و افادتهم
وعزز اماره الامير محمد بن عامر بطبيعه
الحال لكن في اثناء عوده الامير محمد بن
عامر اصيب بمرض الجدري في الطريق فتوفي
تقريبا في نواحي بيشه في نفس السنه 117
ابو نقطه يعتبر
السعوديه
كبير جدا في ضم جنوب غرب الجزيره العربيه
جنوب الجزيره العربيه الجزيره العربيه
وكانت له الحملات اشكاليه كبيره جدا سواء
على الحجاز والمخلاف سليمان او اليمن
في سنه 1217 في نفس العام
كانت كان المخلاف السليماني قد استعصى على
تقبل ان ينضم الى الدوله السعوديه الاولى
بسبب ذلك وجود الشريف حموده ابو مسمار
الخيرات
وكذلك ابن عمه الشريف او ابن اخيه الشريف
علي بن حيدر
هناك شرايا ارسلها السعوديون لكن لم تحقق
شيئا كبيرا يعني
على سريرها الامير عبد الوهاب عامر
عبد الوهاب ابن عامر جيش كبير جدا
ورقم المراسلات التي حدثت بينه وبين شريف
حموده ابو مسمار الا انه شريف محمود ابو
مسمار رفض
التسليم
وعلى اثر ذلك
حدثت معركه ابو عريش المشهوره
والتي كان القتلى فيها بالمئات كان القتل
فيها شديدا للغايه
واتمكن الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
سيطره النفوذ السعودي على منطقه المخلاف
السليماني
واقرار الشريف حموده ابو مسمار اميرا على
المخلاف سليمان
وهذا كان سيكون له تبعاته او مشاكل كثيره
بالنسبه الى الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
وبالنسبه الى الدوله السعوديه الاولى
سيقتل الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
طب انا ودي اعرف الحين ايش صار على اليزيد
السياسي
المرويات حتى كلهم حضور اشتراك في بعض
يعني في اشارات
[موسيقى]
يعني كان لهم حضور في في ربما في هذه
الاماره لكنهم فعليا لم يعد لهم يعني شيء
يذكر نعم
وكيف
كان المجتمع العسيري المجتمع في عسير عفوا
همم مع حكم الدوله السعوديه الاولى
همم
دخلت في تاريخ ابدا ابدا والعلماء العلماء
الذين كانوا موجودين وكبار علماء ثقيلين
يعني يعتبرون العلامه احمد بن عبد القادر
الحمضي والعلامه ابنه القاضي محمد بن احمد
العجيلي وكذلك العلامه محمد بن هادي
العجيلي كلها هؤلاء ترى همم
الدوله السعوديه الاولى تايدا كبيره جدا
في المصنفات
وارسل القصائد والاشعار التي تبارك جهود
الدوله السعوديه الاولى وتبارك جهود
الائمه السعوديين وتبارك جهود ايضا همم
الامراء الذين كانوا موجودين في منطقه
عسير من الضحك
يعني لعل من اشهرها مثلا قصيده محمد بن
احمد القاضي عصائب في نجد تمهدوا للمهدي
وتحيي مواد الدين في القرب والبعد وهي على
كانها قصيده معارضه
او على غرار من حيث المبنى على غرار قصيده
ابن الامير الصنعاني سلام على المجتمع من
حلفتي وان كانت تسليما على البعد
فكان هناك سعيد كان هناك شهيد كبير جدا
ليه ليه لانضمام عشرين للدوله السعوديه
الاولى وكان لهم حضور محمد بن احمد القاضي
محمد بن احمد الحفظي ياريت عند البهكري
وغيره انه كان في حمله الامير عبد الوهاب
بن عامر لاقناع علماء المخلاف سليمان
اقناع علماء المخلاف سليمان
وايضا
يعني التاثير على على عدم معارضه النفوذ
النفوذ الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر ومن
وراء طبعا النفوذ السعودي
بس مثلا في في روايات اللي تقول انه همم
كانت في همم في سرات عسير انه نزعت همم
نزع السلاح من القبائل بينما رفضت همم
رجال صحيح صحيح هناك هناك قلق حدثت مثلا
في منطقه اتهمت عشير ولكن هذه الحادثه لم
تكن ترى مثاره اشكال كبير جدا لن تكون
مثاره اشكال كبيره جدا
ودليل ذلك ان الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
ترى سوفتا منها هؤلاء والتجهه الى همم الى
الدرعيه وانتهى الاشكال وانتهى الاشكال
بالكامل هو كان يتعلق بتسليم السلاح وهذا
الامر
طيب في بحث علي بن محمد ابو داحسن
بين الانضمام
فهي اقرب لهم من جيرانه مزيديه
والاسماعيلي والسبب الثاني هو موجود طموح
راسي
انا لا ارى هذا الراي ابدا كلا الرايين لا
اراهما
ربما الراي الثاني ربما فيه نوع من الوجاه
لكن فيه راي اقوى منه او ارجح منها وهو
انه المجتمع كالذي حاله من التقدم
تعود الى سنه 1177 مرحله تسرب الدعوه وهذا
طبيعي
في عام 1160 تقريبا
في سنه 1160 في نفس العام تقريبا وصلت الى
اليمن
نراه او ما نقرا من مدونات بان حدثت همم
بدات الهجرات بدات التشرب الافكار والدعوه
حدث في سنه 1177 وهذا هو المنظر
من 1177 حتى 1215 وانتقال او
انضمام عسيري لكن في الدوله السعوديه
الاولى حدث التبني او حدث الايمان الكامل
هناك تبني اجتماعي حدث
فمساله انه انه بهذه المنطقه عسير في ذلك
الوقت ما يضحك مساله التمذهب وكذا
كانوا بعيدين جدا عن مساله ما يعتمل في
صنعاء واحوازها في المساله المذهبيه
والشيب والشكر يعني
ودى المنبه لانه
الحاله المذهبيه في في
اليمن الحاله الزيديه في اليمن تحديدا او
المذهب الزيدي في اليمن في ذلك الوقت
كان هناك علماء مجتهدين علماء مجتهدين
والتراث الجديد والتراث طبعا
والغلوب وفي كثير من التسامح والانفتاح
في تلك الفتره تحديدا
لم يكن هناك اي تاثير حتى يكون عند
المجتمع تصور بانه ننضم مثلا الى كان في
الدوله السعوديه الاولى بغض في التراث
الزيدي
المذهب الزيدي كان بعيد بالمره المشكله
على نفس الخريطه المذهبيه او على نفس
السياق المذهبي في الحجاز وفي اتهامه نفس
كان هناك
الطريقه او الطريقه الصوفيه همم فقها
شوافع عقيده اشاعر بهذا الشكل
وجود تركيات
هذا المفهوم صعب شويه
كيف كل الموضوع صعب اليوم
اتحدث عن قضيه اذا يعني ما المقصود
بالشركيات
هل تقصد هل تقصد ان هناك مثلا ربما يكون
هناك ثقافه
او اولياء او كذا طبيعي ربما يكون موجود
لا ربما يكون موجود لان التراث التراث او
همم
او الثقافه الدينيه المتصوفه الشافعيه في
تلك الفتره كانت يعني يعني تهتموا كثيرا
بثقافه الاولياء
تهتمم
بالمزارات في اوروبا ربما يكون هناك وهذا
همم يعني همم
وهذا كان شائدا موجود في الجزيره العربيه
فاذا كان موجودا في اكثر مناطق الجزيره
العربيه
فلا هي ما الذي يمنع ان تكون عشيره ايضا
فيها مجرات او فيها نوع من التبرك
بالاضرحه المنطقه التي كانت اقل منطقه في
راي لم يكن فيها التبرك بالاضرحه
والمزارات
والمنطقه الهضبه السيديه في اليمن
انتقال ال ال
الاماره من محمد الى عبد الوهاب الى طامي
هذه الانتقالات اثرت على اسير
لا بالعكس هي كانت هي كان لكل لكل انتقال
سياقه تاريخي وكانت في بعض الاحيان كانت
كما يقال فلته والسبب في ذلك همم كبر
الاحداث التاريخيه
الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر قد حملات شهوات
طبعا على منطقه الحجاز
في سنه 1218 و1219 ثم 12020
في سنه 1219 كانت هي بتعرف انه شريف غالب
مساعد في سنه 1218 حصره الامير سعود وقتها
كان يسمى امير الامام عبد العزيز لم يزال
حيا
ف- وتمكن الامام سعود من من السيطره على
مكه المكرمه ولا الشريف غالب مساعد كفى
الى منطقه او الى مدينه جده
حاصره الامير سعود لكن لم يحدث ااا لم
يحقق
الامير سعود اي يعني مكسب باعتبار انه كان
هناك مدد بحري من قبل الباب العالي الشريف
غالب وكانت المدينه محصنه بشكل جيد وكان
هناك حامي عثمانيه فكان الامر يعني صعب
وسيطر على مكه
الامام عبد العزيز
ضروره حصار الشريف غالب مساعد
ومحاوله ادخال الحجاج في كنا في الدوله
السعوديه
يسيطر الامير عبد الوهاب على القنفذه وعلى
الليث
واضح انه كان يريد حصر نفوذ الشريف غالب
في في مكه وجده بعد ذلك في عام 1218
يقيم حوالي
لمده 70 يوما في ضواحي يلملم والسعوديه
ويثبت نفوذ الدوله السعوديه الاولى في
جنوب مكه
ويرسل كثير من القارات والشراييا على تلك
المناطق ويخضعها للدوله السعوديه الاولى
في سنه 1219
يصطدم مع الشريف غالب مساعد في معركه
السعديه المشهوره وهي معركه ضخمه جدا يقال
انه قتل من الطرفين حوالي 3000 مقاتل
وذكرها ابن بشير وذكرها دحلان في خلاصته
وذكرتها صاحب الظل الممدود
وكانت معركه يعني تقريبا فاصله حطمت قدرات
شريف غالب العسكريه ولذلك في السنه التي
تليها 1,220 استسلم الشريف غالب
وكان طبعا على بغض شديد اللي همم شهره
عثمان المضايفي الذي حاج الى السعوديه
فلم يريد ان ان يكسب مجد التسليم لهذا
الرجل فا راى انه يسلم الامير عبد الوهاب
بن عامر والامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر كانت
انا ذاك جيوشه على مشارف الحجاز
فحدث تسليم المدينه له في سنه 1220
1800 ميلادي
وعلى اثر ذلك اصبح الحجاج منظويا تحت سلطه
الدرعيه
فكان لعسير دور الجوهري في توسع الدوله
السعوديه
الاولى على منطقه غرب وجنوب الجزيره
العربيه
وكان قويا قويا نفوذ بدرجه كبيره الى درجه
الرحاله
وصل الى مكه في سنه 12020 19
السعوديه مع الامام سعود الكبير الامير
عبد الوهاب ومع الجميع قائد الدوله
السعوديه كان يقول بالحرف ان الرجل الثاني
في الدوله السعوديه
كان الرجل كان له حضور قوي جدا
على اثر ذلك هذا الامير
بعد ان استولى ايضا على منطقه المخلاف
الشيباني ارسل قوه عسكريه كبيره سيطره على
منطقه بدر في نجران
عسكريه كبيره جدا بامر الامام سعود بن عبد
العزيز الكبير
بعد عام 12220
يبدا شريف محمود ابو مسمار
يتمرد على الدوله السعوديه الاولى من خلال
رفض الضرائب او من خلال رفض ان يدفع
الجبايات
التيماني
وكانت اول بذور المشكله حين
طالبه الشريف محمود ابو مسمار بيفصلي
فصل المخلاف السليماني اداريا عن اماره
عبد الوهاب بن عامر الامير
الامام سعود
استجاب لي لان يفصل المخلاف السليماني
فكان هذا السبب لي لان يقوم الامام سعود
الشريف محمود ابو مسمار يتوسع في في تهامه
اليمن باسم الامام سعود طبعا
لكن اصبح يتقوا يتقوى تقوى مع الوقت حتى
في نهايه المطاف بدا يتمرر
في سنه وليس اسباب كثيره واحداث تاريخيه
كبيره
الامام سعود الكبير راى انه لابد من
استدعاء الرجل
في حج عام 1223
في مكه
بريح الدوله
ولمجده الشخصيه
كان الامير عبد الوهاب ينظر الى هذه
المساله
عبد الوهاب الامام سعود
بيحضارهم جميعا في مكه في حج عام 1123
بالفعل الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
الشريف حمود فقد بعث بعض اسرته
غضب الامير الامام سعود الكبير غضبا شديدا
جدا
لاسباب كثيره لدرجه انه شك شك بعض العملات
باسمه وهذا يعتبر نوع من انواع السياده
ونوع من انواع الاستقلال كما تعلمون
وهذا الشباب شريف حموده ابو مسمار يعتبره
داهيه العرب داهيه في وقته يعتبر قائد
سياسي محمد
الخلاصه
ارسلت الجيوش يقودها الامير عبد الوهاب بن
عامر وكانت الاعداد غيره جدا يعني ربما
الشوكاني هو المقل يقول ان عدد الشوكاني
وغيره لعله البكلي يقول ان عدد مقاتل
الامير عبد الوهاب 20 الف وبعضهم وصل الى
50,000
وبعدين
الشريف
لقتال الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر الدرعيه
ارسلت
قادتها العسكريين ضمنهم بعض
اخوه عثمان المضايف في
قائد العسكري اصابه العتيبي وغيرهم
و بنشكبان وغيرهم اشارتي لانها الامير عبد
الوهاب بن عامر يكون هو صاحب القائد العام
للحمله
في خلال مضيئه هذه الحمله حتى وصلت الى
وادي بيش شمال
كان يظن انه انه سيبقى في مدينته و
ستحاصره القوه السعوديه
لكن حدث
بحسب بعض المصادر انه باغه القوات
السعوديه
وعلى اثر هذه المباغته والحجمه
او الاشتباك قتل الامير عبد الوهاب بن
عامر
فيقول انه الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
فتى الا ربحه
وحمل على حامل الرايه البكيليه
في اليمن قبيله كان كان الشريف حمود ابو
مسمار يستمده معه
فحمل على حامل الرايه البكيليه فقط
الجيش
رصاصه على الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر في
اثناء حمله
فانتصر جيش الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
بحسب ايضا جحاف يقول انه ثمانيه اشخاص من
اسره طالب
من اخوه الامير عبد الوهاب وابناء عمومته
حين راوا عبد الوهاب بن عامر قتيلا عافوا
الحياه
حتى قتلوا
ويقدم حفظ وصف شرياني كبير جدا ومشاهد
يعني عجيبه وهو رجل مؤرخ كان معاصر
الاحداث وفي نفس الوقت
في في الكتابه التاريخيه واستحضار
المعلومات التاريخيه بشيء يدعوحشه يعني هو
من اعظم مؤرخ الجزيره العربيه يعني في
وقته تقريبا
الحاصل انه الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر قتل
وبحسب المصادر
يقول جحافه ايضا
وطار في جميع نشط وعسير قتل ابي نقطه وكان
لا يشاؤون به احد
كما يقابل وحتى البهكلي رغم ان البهكلي هو
من رجالات الشريفه
الا ان يثني على الامير عبد الوهاب بن
عامر
قتل الامير الفارس
الباسل عبد الوهاب بن عامر قائد تلك
البنود او قائد تلك الجنود ومبندت تلك
البنود عند عند ثم يصف المكان فيه
رغم ان البهكري
الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر
لكن
ثقيل جدا في منطقه جنوب مجلس العربيه
في هذه المعمعه يتولى الامير طامي بوشعيب
بن عمي وكان ذراع ايمن كان ذراع لايمن
للامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر ويبدا تبدا
امارته من سنه 1224 من حين مقتل
الامير عبد الوهاب بن عامر حكم لمده سته
سنوات
كل جهود الامير طامي
محدد الاول
الدوله السعوديه الاولى
الامر الاخر والثاني الدفاع عن الدوله
السعوديه الاولى لانه بدات الان تتدفق
حملات محمد علي باشا
كانت كل جهوده السياسيه والعسكريه
لا تخرج عنهم
فيما يخص المحدد الاول
ان يستولي على منطقه المخلاف السليماني
وبذل جهود كبيره وسيطر على منطقه تهامه
اليمن
سيطره على اللحيه سيطره على الحديده
وهذا
هذا الاستيلاء او هذا الانطواء
هذا يثبت انه في مناطق مناطق لم تخضع
لليمن السياسي لفترات طويله خضعت لمنطقه
عشيره
الامير
والحديده في سنه 1225 ثم ايضا قاتل الشريف
حموده ابو مسمار في معركه مشهوره تسمى
معركه بربر
هجما الشريف حمود
[موسيقى]
رامي حقيقه في
التضييق الخناق على الشريف محمود ابو
مسمار ومحاصالته
بالنفوذ السعودي
انه الدوله السعوديه الاولى تهامها امر
كبير وهم يخص بدايه تدفق حملات محمد علي
باشا سنه 1226
وعلى اثر ذلك تنفس السعداء طبعا الشريف
محمود ابو مسمار بهذه وكذلك حتى امام
اليمن
وعلى اثر ذلك
لانه التمدد السعودي كان دائما يتجه جنوب
عن طريق امراه عشيره حتى عن طريق الشريف
حموده ابو مسمار في فتره من الفترات
الامام اليمن تنفس الشهداء الامام المتوكل
في هذه الاثناء كان الامام المتوكل ابن
الامام المنصور
بدات حملات طوسون باشا في سنه 1226 1811
واشتركت
او
اشتراك الامير طامي مش عارف في معركه وادي
الصفراء بمقاتلي مشتركه منطقه عسير
بمقاتلها
وانتصرت القوات السعوديه انتصارا مبينا
وكبيرا في في معركه وادي الصفراء
بحسب بعض الروايات انه كان القتلى بالالاف
تقريبا حوالي اربعه الاف او كذا
يؤخذ على القوات السعوديه في هذه
في هذه التوقيت بانها لم تطارد فلول
القوات العثمانيه والقوات مباشر
لانه ربما يكون سبب ذلك خوفهم من بعض
الكائن
او ربما انه كان هناك ايضا قتله كثر في في
صفوف القوات السعوديه وبين حوالي تقريبا
600 قتيل بحسب بعض الروايات على ما اذكر
كيف
ومحمد علي باشا بدا
يرسل القوات
والتعزيزات العسكريه
وبالفعل
[موسيقى]
طوسون باشا قبيله تقدمه عمل خطه
بدرجه كبيره جدا وهم مراسله الشريف غالب
الدوله السعوديه الاولى
لفتح ابواب الحجاز مباشر
[موسيقى]
في مدينه المنوره
اتمنى بحسب
المصادر الموجوده
كان قائد الحصار واحد اسمه احمد بونابرت
احمد
وكان رجل مشهور بالشراسه
هؤلاء
المقاتلين الامان بعد حصار شديد استمر
لعده اسابيع طبعا وبعد ان ان يئس هؤلاء
المقاتلون من وجود الندات او فك للحصار
اعطاهم الامان مقابل التسليم
[موسيقى]
وسلموا انفسهم
فقام بقتلهم بكره ابيهم في انتهاك مصارف
وكان عدد القتلى تقريبا
وبعض المصادر تقوم بالالف لكنهم على اقل
تقدير بالمئات
وفي اثناء النقش طبعا في الحوادث
التاريخيه مثل هذه الحوادث التاريخيه انا
اذكر انه بركات السويسري الرحاله
يقول ان احمد بن عبرت جميع الجماجم من
القتلى
ووضعهم على هيئه برج على اطراف المدينه
على اطراف المدينه المنوره في عمليه يعني
ارهابيه او في عمليه
مخطوط يمني يشير يقول بالنص انه في سنه
1227 اخبر الحاج منصرفه في اثناء انصرفيه
انهم وجدوا قبه معموره من اتباع السعوديه
قبه معموره من جماجم القتل
والكلى الموردين مختلفين يعني لهذا المصدر
بركات ياخذه مع مشاهداته او من عاسره او
من مشاهده هذه
الرجل ياخذ اليمني المؤرخ اليمني ياخذ من
هؤلاء الحجاج فالموارد المختلفه ومع ذلك
اتفقوا هذا يشير الى انه الحقيقه فعلا
واقع فعلا لم تذكر في المصادر المحليه
الاخرى
سوء النجديه او الحجازيه او غيره
الحاصل انه
اصبحت استولى على المدينه المنوره رسوم
باشا ثم فتحت ابواب الحجاز تمت السيطره
على منطقه
مكه وجده والطائف
وكان ذلك في غضون سنه 12828
واصبحت كفاءه القوات السعوديه واصبحت
النقطه الاستراتيجيه لهم هي منطقه
فارس
غاليه
في سبيل الله
في سبيل الهاب حماسه المقاومين
كانت منطقه استراتيجيه باعتبار النهائي
تربط بين المقاتلين القادمين من وسط
الجزيره العربيه والقادمين من جنوب
افريقيا جزيره العربيه
في الحجاز يعني كانت نقطه مهمه جدا
محمد علي باشا
حمله مكونه من 4000 سنتيم يصلون الى
الحجاز
واول قرار اتخذه
هو الامساك بالشريفه وهذا جزاء سنمار
يفكر محمد علي باشا في هذه الاثناء تحديدا
كان الامير سامي بن شعيب يقوم بها هجمات
وغارات عسكريه على منطقه جنوب الحجاز على
منطقه بحره على منطقه الليف وسبب
سببت يعني
محمد علي باشا
محمد علي باشا اراد ان يضع له قاعده
متقدمه في منطقه عسير اراد ان يسيطر على
مدينه القنفذه
يتوسط تقريبا في جنوب الحجاز وشمال
ابتهامات عسير وبالفعل
تاتي قوات محمد علي باشا وتسيطر على
القنفذه
واضح انه هناك عيون او استخبارات لدى
الامير طعمي شعيب ويداهم مدينه القنفذه
بحوالي 10000 نقدم هؤلاء
الذين استولوا
العثمانيون الذين
وتدور معركه شرسه جدا
يقتل حوالي 1000 مقاتل او جندي من اتباع
محمد علي باشا
يتقدم يحاول ان يتقدم
محمد علي باشا عن طريق بلاد غامد وزهراء
اثر ان يتقدم عن طريق المتن الجبلي بدل
الساحلي وكان هناك قائد المشهور بخروش
كان هناك مسيطر على منطقه زهران وكذا
ومتابع للدوله السعوديه
[موسيقى]
في منطقه الارطاويه
او القطاوله قطاوله
في هذه القريه
يتفاجيء
العثمانيون بقدوم ايضا حمله
فك الحصار ويهزم ايضا هزيمه ساحقه
محمد علي باشا
يصبح في حرج كبير جدا فيه داخل الحجاز او
في منطقه الحجاج
[موسيقى]
المقاتلين السعوديين الى الى معركه فاصله
تحسب المساله
يتجهون يتجه الى منطقه تربه وهو كان واضح
من هذه
من هذه العمليه ما يريد فك الارتباط بين
المقاتلين القادم من وسط الجزيره العربيه
وبين القادمين ايضا من جنوب الجزيره
العربيه
طبعا من من الاشياء المحزنه والمؤسفه انه
في تلك الفتره يموت الامام سعود الكبير
قبيلها في سنه 1229 1814 ميلادي قبيل باسل
والامام عبد الله بن سعود قائد عظيم
وشجاع جدا
الفروسيه ولا في رائحه التدبير العسكري
لكن هناك ظروف كثيره جدا هي التي لم تساعد
في في المساله كم من اهم تفوق السلاح
العثماني كما من اهم وجود جيش منظم
وامدادات متواصله
في كل هذه الاسباب طبعا تحمل بلا غيبه
يعني
اضافه الى وجود
وجود ولاحي يعني يعني وجوده وبعض القيادات
التي في نهايه المطاف انضمت الى مثل
الحملات محمد علي باشا هذا لا شكلنا فت في
عضد همم الدوله السعوديه الاولى بلا شك
الحاصل انه
تحشد القوات السعوديه حوالي 30,000 مقاتل
يقودها الامير فيصل بن سعود ياتي من وسط
الجزيره العربيه ب 10,000 فقط
وكان دائما المقاتل السعودي بحسب المصادر
من عادته انه يقاتل من وراء التلال او من
من او من خلف الحجون اللي كانت موجوده
وسبب في ذلك هو اللي لتفادي ضعف السلاح في
سلاح العسكري محمد علي باشا بتدبيره منه
يعني حاول ان يبين لهم انه حزن
فاطبق عليهم وحدثت بينهم معركه شرسه جدا
ابن بشر لانه متعاطف
فيقول انه عدد القتلى 100
شخصيات قتيل فقط
من الجيش القوات لاميه الامير الامير فيصل
بن سعود في حين سويسري يقول عدد القتلى
تقريبا يكون 5000
وهذا هو الادب المنطقي
وعلى اثر ذلك وطبعا في مشاهد كبيره جدا
وبطوليه وسرياليه حتى ذكره
[موسيقى]
اقدامهم ارجلهم لكي لا يغفر ثلاث
وانهم قتلوا عن بكره
وكان هذا
[موسيقى]
على فكره هذا هذه
وهؤلاء المقاتلين
الى اليوم يعني حتى عشيرتهم اصبحت اشبه ما
تكون مثل الاعتداء او النخوه يقال لهم
صبيان الركبه اذا اذا احتفلوا
نزلوا معروفين معلومات
هذه الاحداث البطوليه الكبيره
ومعه هزيمه القوات السعوديه وانتصار محمد
علي باشا يتقدم جنوب يتقدم
من الواضح انه سبب في ذلك
استراتيجي بحث يتعلق بتامين منطقه الحجاز
والتفرغ لاحقا الى منطقه نجد وهو مامون
الظهر
كامله
انه انه لكي يسيطر على منطقه الحجاز
بالكامل لابد من السيطره على منطقه عشيره
وهذه المساله هي مساله محسومه في التاريخ
الحديث
الدوله السعوديه الاولى حين سيطرت على
منطقه الحجاز لم تسيطر عليهن بعد ما سيطرت
على منطقه عسير
ثم حين جاء الملك عبد العزيز لم يسيطر على
منطقه الحجاز الا حين سيطر على منطقه عسير
قبيلها بعده فالعمليه محسومه تماما
السيطره على منطقه عسير يعني ان تضع شده
بينك وبين اليمن
وفي نفس الوقت يعني انتم من الحجاج بشكل
نهائي
في اول المناطق مناطق المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي منتظمه ومرتبطه في بعضها
البعض ولذلك حتى الملك المؤسس لاحقا ربما
سنه تحدث
نظام منطقه عسير فقط وانما
يترتب عليه النتائج
وضع سد هنا في اليمن امام اليمن
والسيطره على منطقه الحجاج بشكل نهائي
تقدمت قوات محمد علي باشا طبعا ما الذي
حدث الذي حدث انه انتهت المقاومه الموحده
بالكامل صار اصبح كله امير يدافع عن بلدته
او منطقته او منطقه نفوذه
تقدم صوب منطقه عسير طبعا في اثناء تقدميه
تلك المناطق هي مناطق مكشوفه سهله للغايه
الامير
على منطقه بيشه ثم دخل الى منطقه الخميس
الجبال الغربيه منطقه عسير
وفي الامير طعمي مش عيب قسم يعني مقاتلين
لثلاثه اقسام قسم في منطقه شمه الطلحه
موجوده في شرق مدينه الشرق بلده الطلب
شمال مدينه ابها منطقه جبليه وعره الى
الدمام
يقود الامير محمد بن احمد المجحمي ابن عمي
وبالفعل
يتجه الجيش وفي وفي اثناء وصوله الى
الطلحه
يتعرض محمد علي باشا كبير جدا يقتل على
مئات القتلى حوالي 300 قاتل
لكن مع ذلك محمد علي باشا
ويدكها بالمدافع على اثر ذلك يعلن محمد بن
احمد في داخل المعاقل والحصون استسلامه
فيستسلموا له اما الامير طه جنوبا
وحين اتجه جنوب ضاقت عليه الارض بماره
ولم يجد بدا من ان يتجه الى غريبه
يا ريت الخبر للوزير الحازمي الحسن بن
خالد الحازمي وهو علامه متوفيه ويعتبر
يعتبر صاحب السيف والقلم في في اماره
الشريف
الى صبيه
يستشيره اين يذهب
اشار عليه
نعمه بان يتجه الى المناطق الشرقيه من مدن
منطقه المخلاف السليماني باتجاه بني مالك
وفيفا بلاد فيفا لانها جبليه صعبه
لكن اذا حمى القدر
انتهى الامر فاا الامير طامي بن شعيب
اشر على ان يذهب الى صبيه الى غريبه
محمد علي باشا يسيطر على منطقه عسير في
هذه الاثنا ثم يرسله كتيبه عسكريه تطارد
الامير سامي محمد علي باشا الرجل
في هذا السياق
يرسل كتيبه يقودها الشريف راجح الشمري
احد الاشراف الموجودين في الحجاز شريف
راجح الشمري رجل قيادي برقمتي طراز
محظو يعني كان دائما كان من قيادات الدوله
السعوديه الاولى
ثم حين جاءت الحرب
قلب ظهر المجن
كان من رجال الشريف غالب حين عرض الدوله
السعوديه الاولى ثم اصبح من رجالات الدوله
السعوديه الاولى ثم الان اصبح من رجالات
محمد علي باشا وحين ارسل محمد علي باشا
الشريف راجح تحديدا لانه يعلم انه سيخاطب
اشراف مثله
وكان حريصا على على الامساك في الامير
سلطان
كبيره في السن طاعنه ربما الثمانين او فوق
اكثر من 70 سنه الى شكل
بحسب الاوصاف التي طلعنا عليها بالفعل
يتجه الشريف راجح ويتفاوض مع الوزير
الحازم وزير الشريفه الى
الامير الى محمد علي باشا
والشريف راجح الشمري
وبالفعل يتجه الى الحجاز ويطاف به في
شوارع وازقه القاهره ثم يرسل الى اسطنبول
في تلك المناطق يقتل في سنه 1230 1815
ميلادي على غرار من سبق مثل الامير عثمان
الذي كان امير على الطائف تقد يتقدم طامي
تقريبا سنه 1928 واخر عام 1928 محمد علي
باشا قبل ان يغادر ويرجع الى
الحجاز
اعدت ترتيب المشهد السياسي في عشير ووضع
بعض الزعماء القبليين الجدد وضع بعض
الموالينه له وهكذا
ويبدو انه ما وصل الى القاهره الا هو محمد
بن احمد الامير الذي يسمى الجزار كنايه عن
بطشه وقوته ولا شك انه بطشه وقوته كانت
بسبب صعب صعوبه المرحله
الامير محمد بن احمد في الثوره على
الحاميات العثمانيه الموجوده التي كان
اشهرها كان اشهرها موجوده في مدينه في
بلده
يطرد هذه الحامل
ويسيطر على المنطقه
ويبدا يريد ان يدرك الثار ايضا من الشريف
الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والامام عبد الله بن سعود في منطقه
يتقدم الامير محمد بن احمد يسيطر على
المنطقي ثم يصطدم مع شريف محمود ابو مسلم
يدخل في حرب ضروس مع شريف حموده ابو مسمار
لكنه يهزم في معركه الدرب ويقتل من اعداد
يقتل من جيشه
لانه يسيطر الان على منطقه المخلاف
السليماني واتهامه اليمن حتى ما ورد على
الاقتصاديه جيده جدا في استطيع ان يحشد
المقاتلات ويستطيع
وهو رجل ايضا فارس على جانب كبير من الذهب
الحمد لله
لكنه لم يستطيع الانتصار في هذه الاثناء
تحدث
حمله اخرى من من محمد علي باشا يرسل حمله
اخرى
للقضاء على الشريف على الامير محمد بن
احمد المتحم وعلى اثر ذلك
ترسل هذه الحمله العسكريه
وتعود وتسيطر على المنطقه يسيطر على
المنطقه
سيطره كبيره جدا
وعلى اثر ذلك ايضا يرجع محمد الامير محمد
بن احمد ويثير مره اخرى
في هذه الاثناء
يبرز الامير سعود
بن محمد
مشهوره تسمى حمله حمله حسن باشا سيطره على
منطقه عسير
وعلى اثر ذلك يبدا يبدا
مع مع ضغط الحملات العثمانيه يبدا هناك
تملك من المجتمع في منطقه عسير يصبح عند
الناس او بعض الاهالي في المنطقه
رغبه في او او تعب او من من ضغط الحملات
العثمانيه يبداون ينقسمون حول شرعيه
الامير محمد
همم
ما حكم السيطره العثمانيه يحكم من عسير
محمد بن احمد
وفي تقريبا في ربما ولاءات او من بعض
الزعماء القبائل
مع ضغط الحملات العسكريه وكذا يبدا هنا
يصعد دور الامير سعيد
في بلده الشجره
ويتفقون مع الامير محمد بن احمد على على
على المقاومه لا يختلفون معه في هذه
المساله المطلقه لكنهم يقولون له بالنص
انه لابد من السجاد بالشريف حموده
ليصبح معنا
وهم في هذه العمليه ان اعتبرها كانت في
غايه الذكاء هم كانوا يريدون توحيد الجبهه
العسكريه ضد قوات محمد علي باشا ضد حملات
لانهم كانوا الان يقاتلون على جبهته
قاتلون الشريف محمود ابو مسمار يقاتلون
محمد علي باشا
بحسب الروايات والمصادر التاريخيه
الموجوده
واضح انه الامراء عشير في تلك الفتره انه
خسر الامير سليم
حمود ابو مسمار
التردد علاقته بمحمد علي باشا
اليمن وسيطر على منطقه تهامه اليمن وموانئ
اليمن
ايضا
الشريف علي بن حيدر كان منافس على السلطه
في ابو عريش لشريف
محمد علي باشا ويقيم في مدينه القنفذه عند
احد القاده ثم جمع
تحريض كبير جدا من هذا الرجل
له موقف واضح
وصار اتجاه العثمانيين ولذلك لم يقبل واضح
انه كان راي الحسن يؤثر في الشريفه
يؤثر في ان يتبنى الشريف محمود
في اخر المطاف ومات قتيلا على يد الاتراك
العثمانيين وهذا من المفارقه ومن حتى من
المفارقات العجيبه وحركه التاريخ بطبيعتها
حركه ماكره يعني مهما كان اذا كان الامير
عبد الوهاب بن عامر قتل في وادي بيش في
الشيباني
الذي سلم الامير سامي
سيقتله مقاتل سيقتله مقاتله الامير سليم
فلول القوات المنهزمه في سنه 1238
هو الامير محمد بن احمد
الامير محمد بن احمد
العثمانيين وبالفعل
ياتي
الشريف محمود ابو مسمار ويقال انه كان
هناك طموح شخصي للسيطره
وايضا هذا ايضا ربما يكون سببا استراتيجيا
وهو اراد ان تكون خطا دفاعيا اولا
تحميل سيطره ايضا على منطقه عسير يعني ان
هناك
من اي حمله قادمه من الشمال وكانت كل
الحملات العسكريه تاتي من الحجاج
اتجاه القوات القوات محمد علي باشا
من منطقه المخلاف السليماني ويصل الى
منطقه تسمى الحمه بين رجال المع والضرب
ويصطدم مع
يصطدم في سنه وكان ذلك في سنه تقريبا 1233
ويقاتل حمله يقودها جمعه اغا وينتشر
انتصار كبير للغايه ويصعد من عقبه
يشير العمراني في تاريخ
الى انه كان يتجه واضح انه كان متجها الى
منطقه الشجر
وفي ذلك طبعا دلاله كبيره جدا
لكن هذا
من
الواضحاته الشخصيه وعلاقاتهم قويه كانت
بهذين
وان وان هناك التوجه وتخوف من رده فعل اذا
انت انت الامير محمد بن احمد وبالفعل ما
كاد يصعد بحسب النصوص تاريخيا وما كان
يصعد الى الشراه حتى
بدا الحصار من مقاتل الامير محمد بن احمد
تقريبا لكنه نجا بعد ان ربما دفع اموالا
ربما دخل تدخل في الامر الامير شهيد ومسلط
او الامير عليكم المهم انهم اطبقوا في
النهايه على مقاتله العدو القادم في هذه
الاثناء الشريف حمود ابو مسمار يصعد من
عقبه ضلع
ويصل الى مدينه ابها ويتجه شمالا ناحيه
عقبه شعار
في اثناء صعود حمله سنان اغا تحدث المعركه
بين قوات الشريف محمود ابو مسمار والحسن
بن خالد الحازمي وقوات الاسنان اخر
بحسب المصادر التي بين ايدينا انه مقاتله
الامراء الثلاثه الامير محمد بن احمد
انهزمت قوات
الشريف الشريف
اقدم المقاتلون بقيه المقاتلين الذين
كانوا مع الامير محمد بن احمد على
تعقب فلول قوات اسنان حتى قتلته هو القائد
وقتلت الشريف منصور بن ناصر الذي كان
معارضا لعمه الشريف محمود ابو مسمار
العثمانيين وايضا قتل حوالي من هذه الحمله
وذهبت الحمله الشجره ماذا
لا نستطيع ان السبيل المشهد السياسي في
عسير مثل الذي سيحدث بعد هذه المعركه خاصه
ما هو نفوذ الشريف محمود ابو مشمار ما هو
نفود الشريعه الامير محمد بن احمد لماذا
لان الشريف
بعد المعركه بعده ايام ماتش في مخيمه او
في معسكره
والروايات حول حول تداعيات وفاته او
اسبابها يعني
لا يمكن القطع فيها هناك من يقول انه
ابناء الامير طعمي بن شعيب
وهناك من يقول انه متى جريحا وهناك من
يقول انه مات مريض
رغم ان هناك
جيوش الشريف محمود انسحبتهم كفاءات على
وجوهها الى المخالف السليماني وبايعه
الشريفه احمد ابن حمود ابن حمود ابو مشمر
وعلى اثر ذلك محمد علي باشا وبسبب حمله
سنان اغا اقام الدنيا ولم يقعدها فارسل
حمله عسكريه كبيره جدا يقودها خليل باشا
سنه 234
يعني خلال ال 100 سنه هي 100 سنه استغرق
الحملات العثمانيه على منطقه عسير
هي تضعف في فتره يقدر ربما ربما يمر عقد
كامل بدون حمله لكن ربما يكون هناك سنه او
ثلاث او سنتين تكون فيها ثلاث اربع حملات
لكنها اكثر من من 100 سنه من سنه 1226
هجريه حتى سنه 1737
كانت
الحملات العثمانيه التي تتوقف مثلا
او امير مثلا تكون
50 تقريبا
واحده كبيره في ذلك الوقت
في هذه الاثناء في هذه اللحظات الدوله
السعوديه
فقط او محصوره في الدرعيه لانه يبدا
الحصار كان كان
موت الشريف محمود ابو مسمار تقريبا في
ربيع الاول في العاشر من ربيع الاول سنه
سقوط الدرعيه كان في ذي القعده من سنه
1233 ولذلك
اصبح النفوذ السعودي فقط في العا في في
الدرعيه
وسيبدا الحصار
على على على
الدرعيه في هذه القوات محمد بن احمد
الان
في بعد
15 الف مقاعد 15000 مقاتل نعم في تلك
الفتره همم سقوط الدوله السعوديه على عسير
سالتك
الحاصل انه محمد علي باشا
[موسيقى]
اصبح هناك
عداء صريحا مع العثمانيين ومع محمد علي
باشا فيرسل حمله عسكريه في 1819 1234
يقودها خليل الباشا يسيطر بها على منطقه
المخلاف السليماني ويطيح باماره الشريف
احمد بن حمود ويعينه الشريف علي بن حيدر
تابعا لمحمد علي باشا لهذا السياق تبقى
عصير خارج المعادله وعلى اثر ذلك يرسل
الامراء عسير طبعا في هذه الفتره او
الامير محمد بن احمد
لمعرفته بحمله الباشا لمعرفته لحمله خليل
باشا
اتجه الى منطقه تهامه لانه الحمله قادمه
من الساحل وكان يظن ان حمله خليل باشا
متوجهه الى بلاد عسير فجمع 15 الف مقاتل
حين نقول 15000 مقاتل
وانتظر حتى قدومها الى بلاد عسير لكنه
تفاجا بانها لم تصل او لم تدخل في عمق
اقليم عسير وانما اتجهت مع الساحل وعبرت
عبرت الثغور البحريه في منطقه عسير حتى
اتجهت الى الى
المخالفه السليمانيه
على اثر ذلك عاد الامير محمد بن احمد الى
مقر امارته وفي خلال ذلك محمد علي باشا
يغلق ملف المخلاف السليماني ويبدا في ملف
عسير ويرسل الشريف
ويبدو انها حمله كبيره جدا وجاءت عن طريق
اكثر من طريق والعددكم
تقريبا
وتمكنت هذه الحمله تمكنت هذه الحمله
دائره طبعا عدت عدت من المعارك لكن من
اشهرها معركه جبل شكر
في المنطقه الشرقيه من من ابها الجنوب
الشرقي باتجاه ما يشم اليوم احد رفيده
وجبل شكر الجبل التاريخ المشهور والذي
نسمه الانظمه تقريبا تدور هناك المعركه
ويقتل فيها الوزير الحسن بن خالد الحازمي
ويؤثره فيها الامير محمد بن احمد المتحمي
وينجو الامير سيد ان شاء الله
ويصبح الامير السعيد ان شاء الله هو
الوحيد
يقتل الامير محمد بن احمد ياسر
المليئه بالحنين
حبه وحنينه لمنطقته التي منها سقى الله
واوطانا تحفه
مطلعها وقد كنت قبل اليوم ارجع وتصغر عندي
معظمه الاعضاء من تحفه وجاد عليها خاطر
ومتراكمي
ومالك والاحلاف من عهد ادم وقيس ابن مسعود
وبكر ابن وائل والمكارم
[موسيقى]
واحده دليلي يا اخي عبد الرحمن على ان
البعد القبلي ليس موجوده هذه القصيده لو
تلاحظ انه الامير يعدد هذه القبائل ويرى
انه ينتمي اليها جميعا هذا ما يثبت بلا شك
ولذلك التعاطي مع التاريخ تاريخ المنطقه
من خلال ابعاد قبليه لي صحيح
[موسيقى]
يا ايها الركب الايمانون وقفوا فليفيكم
وصيه نهائي
فعرجوا صدور العملات الروازم الى طبق بحيث
القرار حيث القناه والصوارم بايدي رجال من
خيار اكارم ولي عندكم لو تعلمون وديعه
واضح انه يقصد لعله يقصد بناته في بعض
التاويلات لانه
لم يكن لديه من
من يحميهم ويدافع عنهم حتى ابنه
لو تعلمون وديعه يقوم بها ذو نسبه في
المتاحم
شتت الدهر
الى اخره وكذلك له قصيده
[موسيقى]
فكم من قتيل في الرغام تمرض الى اخر
القصيده وشاعر ضليع وقوي جدا وهذا ايضا
يعكس
ثقافتهم يعاكس بانه كانوا على جانب كبير
من الثقافه وعلى على جانب كبير من الادب
ولديهم كثير من المعرفه سؤال معرفه
الادبيه او حتى الثقافيه
وحتى الامير مداوي ايضا ابنه كانت لديه
يعني
طيب النبته بالعطري سلام على اعلامها
واكلامها سلام على سكانها البدوي تحيه تصب
قد برى الشوق جسمه
واجمعه من نار الجو
وان كنت في مصري واضح انه كان ماشور في
مصر وما كنت من من يبري الشوق جسمه لغير
القناه والبيض والضمر والشكر الى ان بدت
لي من سعاد محاسبه مهجتي من حيث ادري ولا
ادري لها شعر كالليل اسود وجيد الريم
والوجهك البدري
صدقت ولكن لا سبيل الى الصبر
حتى في القبر تذكرتها وحولي حراس حراس
تذكرتها والليل قد ما انت جنحه وحولي حراس
حراس على اسره
المشرفيه يقصد الاتراك انهم كان
المستصحب المشرفيه كان على اعطائها لها
باليمن الجمري ويممت ارضا لا انيس بها سوى
الذئب يعوي من امامي وفي اثري وسيرت
اقدامي ذراعا لقفرها حتى قطعته حتى قطعتها
ووصلت بني شهري والقصيده طويله الطويله
طويله الى ان يقول
فان رغبت عني سعاد فانني اشد على خطبه
الزمان من الصخر لهمه تعلو على كل همه
تبلغني المقصود بالمده في عمري
سواء ومن يدري قد كنت في عرق واسعد الوراء
وحولي قوم
بلده طبعا قد كنت في عرق اللواء اسعد
الوراء وحول قوم يعرفون به قدري فطورا
تراني فانماري وثاره بخوبرا بين الشيخ
والرد والنهر فيا ايها الريح اليمانيه ابل
يا عمنا مني سلام بلا حصري فلولاهم ما حزن
الزمان الذي صبري عليهم مدى الايام مني
تحيه يفوق شفائها المسك والعنبر البحري
فجسمى بمصر والفؤاد ولديه
هجري ولكنني ارجو الاله وفضل علينا ان
يبدل العشره الى اخر القصيده
فتعكس جزاء لو تعكس حياتهم الثقافيه التي
كانت متميزه رغم انهم ماذا حين تنظر الى
ما فعلوها او اجار ان تقول لم يكن لديهم
حتى الوقت الكافي للقراءه والاطلاع وكذا
الحاصل انه بهذا الاسم تسقط اماره الامير
محمد بن احمد في سنه 1234
اي بعد سقوط الدرعيه بضعه اشهر
وتدخل منطقه عسير في نفقه
تسيطر القوات العثمانيه والحميات
العثمانيه على المنطقه
ويستمر على حد تعبير بعض المؤرخين في
المنطقه يقولون وتب في عشير الفساد والبغي
او كما بسبب وفاه الحب
والحاميات العثمانيه ووضعت من يتواضعون
معهم لكن
في في فجاه
يتغير مشهد بالكامل في سنه 1183 بعدها
باربع سنوات
على يدي ثوره الامير
اخو الشريف
هناك استنزاف هدف استنزاف كبير له في في
على المستوى البشري
وحدث له ايضا استنزاف كبير في مساله
الاقتصاديه
وايضا ايضا هناك قلاقل واضطرابات امنيه
شديده للغايه وبالتالي بالتالي صار الوضع
معقد وهذا ما ذكره في بعض الحوليات
الحمضيه
في تلك الفتره لكن
يحدث ما يقلب المعادله
في عام 1238 طبعا كان هناك اصلا لما حدث
في عام 1238
1823 تقريبا ميلادي
تحدث يحدث نوع من التمرد في منطقه وادي
الدواسر
والحكومه محمد علي باشا في الحجاز
اراده ان تخمد هذا التمرد الحمله عسكريه
لكن
يبدو ان يبدو انه هذا اسلوب من اساليب
السيطره ارادت ان تجمع شوكات القبائل
الموجوده في منطقه عسير واللي يساندون
الحمله العسكريه المتجهه الى وادي الدواسر
خاضعين وكلفوا بذلك الشريف هزاع بن عمر
والشريف محمد بن عون ايضا يعتبر شريف مكه
كان الاجتماع في منطقه وادي سليم منطقه
وادي السليل هي منطقه تقع الى شرق منطقه
عسير اتجاه على الطريق ليست السليل ولكن
السليل
ليست بعيده كثيره من بيشه
بدات شوكات القبائل
العثمانيه التي موجوده
كان الامير سعيد
هو ومن معه
[موسيقى]
انه لديه تحفظ على مساله الذهاب
او
لانه هناك وثيقه عثمانيا
يتحدث عن تجهيزه للثوره
قبل الثوره بثلاثه اشهر او اربعه اشهر
كامله
العثمانيين لكن يبدو انه هذا السبب هو ال
ال الحافز الرئيسي
والشباب المباشر الذي دفعه الى هذه
العمليه وبالفعل
بحسب الروايه بحسب المصادر بما فيها
الوثائق العثمانيه يقولون انه دخل في
الجدل مع مع شريف
دخل في جدل وكان شوكات القبائل موجوده
المقاتلين من جميع ارجاء منطقه عسير
موجودين والرجل كان كبيره في السن اكثر من
70 سنه عمره
وبحسب الروايه الموجوده
طبعا
تذكر هذه الواقعه تذكر نفس العمليه لكنها
تضيف تضيف بما يعتمر في من خلال المجتمع
يعني
وكانها يعني تصف
هذه الحركه
يقال انه فيها احد الكهول الذين كانوا
موجودين في ساحه
هذه الواقعه فمن هول الموقف يقال انه صرخ
وقال افرح يا سعيد ولا تحزن والله انه
احتفل الملك
او يعني
كانه بسق ملكه واعطاك او كذا
او المجتمع يتعامل معها باثر رجل
من الذي حدث تقريبا او ما الالات هذه
الواقع وبالفعل غضب الامير سليم مقره
[موسيقى]
وكانه هناك كثير من المقاتلين
احمد باشا
العمليه
وصرفته وشريف محمد بن عون واتجه الى وادي
الدواسر على اساس ينهون التمرد
البقيه وبالفعل
يصلون الى منطقه وادي الدواسر ينهون
التمرد الاكشن واذا بالامور الدنيا يعني
كما يقال في منطقه عسير
يسالهم الخبر تردهم الاخبار طبعا
يلتقي مع
احد او بعض المكونات القبليه باتهامه عسير
ويحدث بينهم اتفاق على ضروره الثوره
ويتفقون على
وجود ضروره العثمانيين نهائيا
في منطقه شمال
وكانت الحاميه الكبرى الموجوده في المنطقه
هي حميه الشريف هزاع بنعون في طبق وبالفعل
يحاسبها
حصار شديد جدا
ويبدا يطرد
الحميات العثمانيه كلها
وعلى اثر ذلك
يلتقون في منطقه شمال
وهي على مشارف الخميس من جهتي الغربيه
او بعض الاحداث التاريخ حركه التاريخ تشبه
القطار او تشبه الخاطر
ما يكون بحدث تاريخي كبير يكون بمثابه
الطرق
وعلى اثر ذلك اما يتقدم على ضوء هذا الحدث
الذي سيحدث
تنظيف مجانا
فانتصر انتصار كبيرا جدا ومؤجرا
وسيطر على
طارت فلول هذه القوات حتى وصلت الى بيشه
وكان من ضمن المطاردين بعض القيادات مثل
شريف راجح
وسيطر على عمق اقليم عشيره ومنذ لحظتها
منذ الانتصار يرسل جيشا الى اقصى جنوب
منطقه عسير وسيطر عليه ثم يرسل جيشنا
ثم يسيطر على منطقه عسير بالكامل من ظهران
الى زهره تقريبا في هذه الفتره وجيزه جدا
ويبدا يوحد او يقوي جبهتها الداخليه
المفتخره والمبتهجه وكان الرجل بحسب
المصادر التاريخيه من ضمن حتى مصدره من
البشر
الدقيق
[موسيقى]
يعني قويه
بمقتضى اراده اراده المجتمع
على ذلك
بعض الوثائق التي تقول في خطاب لها سنه
الى الى احد اعيان الحجاز فيقول اما
الباشا
وبالهجته الدارجه
اما الباشا يقصد محمد علي باشا نفسي في
مصر فلا نرى الخط الاحمر
[موسيقى]
واعلموا بارك الله فيكم انما ما فعلنا او
بما معناه كان بمحضري
كبار
ثم عدد كل المكونات القبليه لم يترك قبيله
ذكره وهذا يدل على انه كان ينطلق منطلق
اجتماعي كبير جدا
وعلى اثر ذلك تقوم اماراته ويضع مقرها
ينقلها من من
الشقه
وتقوم هذه الاماره في سنه
1238 1822
محمد علي باشا يرسله الحمله في سنه 1239
ويرسلوا حمله اخرى في سنه 1240 ويستطيع
الامير
صاحب مكيده صاحب
صاحب عزيمه على القتال وكان وكان ايضا
محظيا او او كان بالاصح محفوفا بالامير
علي بن مجثل وهو قائد ايضا وهو اخوه وابن
عمه في نفس الوقت
فكان يترك في الامير سليم مسلط من حسب سير
المعارك في سنه 1239 وكذلك 1240 كان يترك
الحملات تتقدم يستنزفها منذ ان تدخل جيش
يستنزف يستنزف حتى اذا وصلت ابها
يدخل
واصبحت ماتت وجهته متعبه فعلا
239 وفعل ذلك في عام 1240 حين مستورد تلك
القوات على الشقق
فكان يخرجها يخرجها صايره وعلى اثر ذلك
ماتش على فراشه سنه 1242 لكن بات تماره
قويه في ذلك الوقت فجاء الامير علي بن
مجفل واماره الامير سعود تقدم جميع هذه
الحملات ودخل محمد علي باشا في اشكالات
خارجيه خاصه مع الدوله العثمانيه وصار في
ملفات اخرى صرفته عن قتال او عن الحرب
منطقه عسير وكانت هذه الاماره قد امتصت
هذه الحملات فاصبح جاء الامير عبد المجيد
وكان كانت الاماره باتت قويه لذلك سياتي
الامير علي بن مجثل ويمد نفوذه السياسي
وجزر دخلك على القاره الافريقي
كل هذه المنطقه ويصبح اقوى امراء جزيره
العربيه
كان ذلك في شوال من سنه 1242
لعلى في سنه 1827 ميلادي عائده بالامر
الامير علي
الامير
كانت على حد قول العلامه الحفظ كلها خيرات
وبركه
يقول حكم الامير علي بن جثل سبع سنوات
كانت كلها خيرات وبركات وبلغني انه حين
مات
فان العامه لم تصب بمثل مصيبته يعني بمثل
مصيبتهم يعني
ولذلك
وكان هناك محمد علي باشا في الحجاز ويضغط
على الحجاج على اماره الحجاز التابعه
لمحمد علي باشا لذلك نراه مثلا يستضيف
الشريف عبد المطلب
طالب
يستضيف المعارضين لمحمد علي باشا لانه
محمد علي باشا يستضيف ايضا بعض القيادات
القبليه المعارضه
الامير سلمان
على فكره المقاومه مقاومه الغازي مقاومه
الوجود العثماني الذي الذي الذي الذي
توالى بشكل كبير تدفق بشكل كبير
فكانت الماء انا فهذا ظني تفسيري المجتمع
كان بحاجه الى الى افراز كيان او تكوين
سياسي
من هذا المشكله الكبيره جدا
محاولات كبيره جدا قام بها الامير علي بن
مجفل لكن المشكله انه شريف علي بن حيدر
كان محميا بجند النظامي بدا بدا هذا
الجندي النظام جنود محمد علي باشا من سنه
1243 يرابطون في في ابو عريش جيش النظامي
حتى تقول المصادر التاريخيه كهيئه الفرنج
[موسيقى]
يبدا الامير علي بمجسن يضيق الخناق على
هذه الاموره يسيطر على المناطق الشماليه
من خلاف يسيطر على المناطق الجنوبيه على
تهامه اليمن لذلك سنلاحظ انه يتمدد جنوبا
في سنه 44 1244 و 1245 هجري يسيطر على
منطقه اللحيه والسيديه وبيت الفقيه
ووادي نور والكونفوت منطقه وادي الصليب
كلها الان في اليمن وعلى منطقه باجل
واميرها واحد اسمها علي بن محمد حميده
يسيطر على هذه المنطقه الشارع
[موسيقى]
في خلال هذه الفتره
لم يبقى الا هذا الجيب الموجود في ابو
عريش
وتاتي الفرصه
يحتاج الى مدافع يحتاج الى مدفعيه ثقيله
تقوم اسلحه عاديه البنادق العاديه
لكن تحدث الان تحدث للغايه
يحدث ثوره تقوم ثوره في في الحجاز
يقودها قائد الباني
تابع لمحمد علي باشا وفرقه الالبانيه يسمى
ترك جبل منصور
كان اقوى امير في المنطقه في جنوب غرب
الجزيره العربيه في غرب الجزيره العربيه
المجفل يقول له حرف الواحد
ويصل الى منطقه المخلاف السليماني
والقوات الاميره عليهم
مطروح محاصره لابو عريش
وبسبب رؤيه العساكر العثمانيه المرابطين
في المدينه وعلي الشريف علي بن حيدر لهذه
القوه المهيبه فاثار وتسليم المدينه
وهو اقليم مهم او ميناء مهم جدا
لكن في اثناء ذلك سنه هذا الكلام في 1248
في اثناء ذلك تلد الاخبار بانه تركج
بالماس اصاب الناس بالعشف
وبالاذلال وهناك بعض الانتهاكات وكذا
كان على جانب كبير من الديانه حتى في
حملته على الكونفوت يقول احد المصادر
اليمنيه
يقول انه رجال الامير عليم لم يكن يحدثهم
ولا نحن وكان مظهرا للدين والامان هكذا
الرجل كان على جانب كبير من التدين
يتقدم
الامير
محمد
وتصبح هذه المنطقه تابعه لكن في اثناء
عوده الامير علي مجفل
اتركهم مرض الموت وهو في الطريق
واشتد عليه المرض وهو في المخلاف
السليماني فرفض الا ان يموت في داره في
الشقق وصل الى داره وتمرد وتوفي حمل على
اكتاف الرجال حتى وصل الى الشقق وتوفي
هناك في سنه 1949
1834 ميلادي تقريبا
انه عهد بالامر
للاسد الضرغام عايض بن مرعي فقام
بالامريكان
اول الامير
سعيد الامير عبد الله
ومحمد
لكن لعل لديه رؤيه او كلام الاماره الى
الامير عائض القمري فتولى الامير عبد
الامير
من هنا
ياتي هذا المفهوم وهذا المصطلح
مده حكمه طويله جدا ومفيده
وفي عهده بدات الاشكالات الحقيقيه لانه
حملات محمد علي باشا استنفت من جديد
في سنه 1249
في نفس اول العام الذي تولى فيه الحكم
ثم في سنه 1250 ترسله حمله مقدره بحوالي
16000 مقاتل
ودون احداثها المؤرخ او الرحاله الفرنسي
كانت معارك كبيره جدا
على جانب كبير من الذهب العسكري وكان عنده
قيادات متمرده يبدولي انا نور انه
المقاتلين الذين كانوا موجودين صار عندهم
لديهم دربه وتمررش من كثره القتال ومن
كثره كان عندهم تصور حتى المقاتل او الخصم
او كذا
فحدث حدثت معارك كبيره جدا رغم انهم سيطره
على عمق اقليم عسير لكن حدثت عمليه
استرداد وتطهير لهذه المناطق حتى تمكنوا
من السيطره وهزيمه الشريف محمد بن عون
واحمد
وعلى اثر ذلك طبعا هذا كان معاصر لحقبه
الامام تركي الامام فيصل بن تركي في
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه
ولذلك
من
القصائد الجميله قصيده علي بن الحسين
القاضي قاضي الامير
اماكن
[موسيقى]
قالت رويدا ابا عبد فانما اضاق بنا ذرعا
شديده توعدي عرمرم جيش مسيقه من مصر
وينظم ساده الرجال بمقلد
فقلت لها من دونكن ودونهم ضبابا حماه
بالحديد المهندي وضربا يزيل الهامه عماره
اجوافه
وفيها اليوث الاسد من كل شيء يصلون هذا
الحرب
حول وجه احياء ظلمنايا اصدرات كل مولدين
خليفه وعصر للحنيفيه مثقفا لمعوجه جديد
وما بدا اسماء مواضع
فقال لك من يوم الحفير وما بدا لريده من
طول الغمام المشييد ومن قبل ذلك يوم
المفضل ومن قبل ذا ويوم المقفضه قد تقضت
امورهم بفاقيره الظهر التي لم تضمدي ومن
قبل ذا يوم عزيزهم ذليل بضرب المشرفي
المهند بايدي رجال من شانه اتجدهم رقى بهم
مجدا حذفتي فليهم بني قحطان مجد فخاره مدى
الدهر في نادي بواد وابنه ثم يسترسل في
القصيده اكثر من 70 بيت لن يصل الى الامام
فيصل التركي
ويقول واشرف على وادي اليمامه قائلا ودمع
كشفاح على الخد والثدي سلام على عبد
العزيز الامام عبد العزيز الامام الثاني
من ائمه الدوله السعوديه الاولى سلام على
عبد العزيز وشيخه وتابع رشد للامام
المجددين دعا الناس دهرا للهدى فاجابه في
امن فمنهم عالمون ومقتدي وعرج بهذات
اليمين وقد هوت على عرفات للرياضي بمقصده
ونادي باعلى الصوت بشرى لفيصل لانه يبشره
بالانتصارات بشرى لي فيصل السادات الملوك
المسددي اليك نظاما نشرته في وقائع على
جحفه للمصري قد شد باليد فعشرون الفا قد
قضى الله منهم فما بين مقتول وعارم مصفدي
ولم ينجي منهم غير قومهم على صافينات
في قليل معودين فقولي دليل القوم هلا
افاده من العلم ان البقي قتاله معتدل
ومهما اعادته الاماني لحربنا نصبنا لهم
امثال لها بالمجددين
الى ان يقول
الى اخر قصيده وهي طويله ملحميه كبيره جدا
بقصيده اخرى قام بها العلامه الفقيه احمد
بن المشرف الاحسائي
نطلعها بشير وسعاده جاء نحو كيف اسعد
بهذه
الانتصارات الكبيره والملاحظه انه علاقه
الائمه السعوديين كانت علاقه متميزه وهي
امتداد ايضا لعلاقه سلافه الامير سليم
على محاربه العثمانيين ورد في الوثائق
العثمانيه ان هناك تنسيق في الوقت الذي
كان فيه الامير سعودته او او يقوم بالثوره
في سنه 1238 كان الامام تركي بن عبد الله
يعمل جاهدا على توحيد منطقه العارض تحديدا
وعلى طرد الغزاه العثمانيين الذين كانوا
موجودين في في منطقه العارض
وكان لهم علاقات كبيره جدا
بالامام فيصل بن تركي لاحقا حتى انه
المؤمن الاسباب التي ادت الى
بعث حمله خورشيد باشا سنه 1254
نفي الامام فيصل بن تركي
واستسلامه او الحمله العثمانيه الضخمه
التي ارسلت على يد خورشيد باشا هو رفض
الامام فيصل بن تركي تقديم الرواحل والدعم
في حملات العثمانيين على على منطقه عسير
فكان افضل الامام فيصل مدعات لان يرسل
محمد علي باشا
جيشم بقياده خورشيد باشا والذي على اثره
انتهت فتره الفتره الاولى من فتره حكم
الامام فيصل بن تركي ولم يعد الا بعد خمس
سنوات تقريبا في سنه 1259 لتقوم فترته
الثانيه حتى عام 1282 وكانت علاقاته
متميزه جدا بالامام بالامير عائض القمري
حكم تقريبا
23 سنه او 24 سنه
وفي خلال هذه الفتره
تمكن يعني صحيح انه حملات محمد علي باشا
خلصت من الخريطه السياسيه خريطه السياسيه
لكنه في نهايه المطاف استطاع انه يدحر هذه
الحملات العسكريه
وضلت منطقه عسير في معزل التام عن عن
حملات محمد علي باشا حتى
اقرار معاهده لندن في سنه 1256 1840
ميلادي والتي تقضي
بانسحاب
قوات محمد علي باشا من خارج ااه مصر جميع
الحملات او جميع القوات العسكريه الموجوده
في الجزيره العربيه جرى سحبها
بمقتضى هذه الاتفاقيه على على خلفيه
شراعيه مع الباب العالي وعلى خلفيه همم
تدخل القوه الاوروبيه في فرض المعاهده
عليه مقابل ان يكون حكمه همم محصورا في
مصر ويكون ايضا تعترف ان يكون حكم مصر
لذريته من بعده
وعلى اثر ذلك سلمت مثل منطقه الحجاز الى
الباب العالي بشكل مباشر
وخلال هذه الفتره تقوى نفوذ الاشراف اصبحت
لهم قوه معتبره الى حد ما وكان وقتها
الشريف محمد بن عون ولذلك صارت منطقه بلاد
غامد وزهران مسرح مسرح
مع الامير عايض مرعي
في في تلك الفتره خاصه
كبيره جدا وهي هزيمه جيشه في معركه رغدان
في بلاد غامد وزهراء واسر تقريبا حوالي
900 مقاتل
ولذلك الامير عايض بن مرعي بسبب هذه
بسبب هؤلاء الاشرف راى
[موسيقى]
انه يعقد اتفاقيات مع حكومه الحجاز
العثمانيه وبالفعل عقد اتفاقا تنازل
بمقتضى عن مناطق شمال عسير مقابل ان يفرج
عن الاسرى الذين كانوا مسجونين في في جده
وبعد ذلك
على منطقه شمال عسير بعد عوده الاسرى
سهران بدون موسيقى
ذهب طبيعي
يعني يعني يعتبرون النسخه الثقافيه واحده
على اثر ذلك
يحاول قدر الامكان السيطره على منطقه
المخلاف السليماني منطقه تهامه اليمن
في تلك الفتره كان الباب العالي يحاول قدر
الامكان السيطره على منطقه على مناطق
تهامه اليمن لانها استراتيجيه بالنسبه لي
ولذلك ان صراع الامير مرعي في شمال عسير
وفي اقصى في الجنوب او جهه تهامه اليمن
ولذلك في سنه 1272
1272 وهو العام الذي توفي فيه
قد حمله عسكريه كبيره جدا على الحديده
لكن من سوء الحظ وتعرض جيشه لحمل وباء
الصفراء
احد الان كانت موجوده في ذلك الوقت
وكان القتل
الذين اصيبوا بهذا الوباء نفسه
وكان قد اراد ان
يخلفه من بعده الامير عبد الله بن علي بن
مشعل بحسب بعض المصادر التاريخيه لم يكن
لكن الامير عبد الله بن علي المجلس الشعب
منهم
وانحصرت
من يخلف الامير علي
في اثنين اما في ابنه محمد
او محمد بن فرح وهو احد رجالات اليزيد
الموجودين في الشقه يعني اعتبرهم من نفس
عشيره الامير ايضا
وكانت تولي اذا انا ذاك كان يقوم على
العراقه والكفاءه
على العلاقه والكفاءه
فحين استغفل امير عبد الله بن علي بن مجفل
كان في اكثر كان قائد عسكريه مشهوره كان
دائما ما يرابط في بلاد غامد وزهران
فان حصلت في بحسب الوثائق العثمانيه عند
الاحيان او كذا او
ال تذهب الى الامير محمد
فتولاها الامير محمد بن عايض وهو انا ذاك
شاب صغير مقارنه بين محمد بن مفرح الذي
كان كبير في الشنطاعنا كان في سنه او في
عمره تقريبا يوازي الامير علي وبحسب
المصادر
او بحسب بعض الوثائق المحليه انه الامير
محمد بن عايض كتب وثيقه في غايه الاهميه
وان له ايضا
مقدار معين من ال من الاموال وكذا ومن
الغلال القادمه من بلاد غامد وزهراء وكذا
وذكر ايضا انه سيكون له بمثابه الولد
لوالده منذ الكلام لذلك كانت وثائق الامير
محمد بن عايض رسائل
القوى السياسيه في الجزيره العربيه وفي
خارجها كان اذا ختم خطاباته او اذا انتهى
من رسائله يقول وفلان وفلان لا فلان يسلم
عليكم والاخ فلان يسلم عليكم والوالد محمد
بن فرح او العم محمد وهو انا ذاك امير
امير
وحين تولى
لم يكن كثيرا وحكم تقريبا لمده ربما يكون
عمرها 24 سنه
حاصل انه انه حدث حدث رئيس جدا غير
المعادلات في المنطقه وفي الجزيره العربيه
بشكل عام
التحديثات الباب العالي قام يحدث اجهزه
عسكريه
ثم كانت الحادثه الكبرى افتتاح قناه
السويس
كان ذلك تقريبا في سنه 1000
تقريبا موافق عام 1869 ميلادي
كان فاتح قناه السويس يعني انتقال المعدات
الثقيله في خلال بضعه ايام الى الى ثور
منطقه عسير وهذا ما لم يكن موجود قبل
ذلك يسهل سيطره قوات القوات الباب العالي
على مناطق
غرب وجنوب الجزيره العربيه
من باب العالي كانوا الشريف محمد بن عمر
كان قويا الى حد ما ثمنه الشريف عبد الله
بن محمد
والنفوذ هم ايضا في اليمن بات بات قويه
للغايه خاصه بعد سيطرتهم حتى سيطروا على
صنعاء مؤقتا في سنه 1264 في
عهد الامير محمد بن عايض وفي النصف الثاني
من عهده
ولكن سيطرتهم كانت على اليمن قويه جدا
وبسبب استشعار الامير محمد بن عايض بانه
في ضيق شديد من هاتين الكتلتين او من هذين
النفوذين
وكلاهما مرتبط بالباب العالي
قرب ان يطهر الساحل اليمني بالكامل من
القوات العثمانيه وبالفعل
حاصر
قام به اكتشاح منطقه المخلاف السليماني
لانه وقتها كانت الثورات متكرره من
الاشراف في المخلاف السليماني اما لدافع
الرغبه في الاستقلال او السلطه العثمانيين
ويبدو انه الامير محمد بن عايض في فترات
كثيره ضاق ضرارا
بتصرفات الاشراف في الاخلاف السليماني
وهذا ما جعله في في تقريبا في مطلع
الثمانينات من القرن الثالث عشر
من خلاف سليمان
ويهدم حتى الحصول والمعاقل التي اخذت عليه
هذا الفعل يعني اخذ عليه انه هدم المعاقل
او الحصون
لكن
تفسير ذلك وهذا ليس تبريره عندما تفسير هو
كثره هاتف هذه الثورات الثورات الاشرف
وهذا مجال مثل العلامه عبد الخالق ابراهيم
الزمزميه اثني عليه بقصيده كبيره يعني
يكون فيه الامير محمد بن عايض المثل في
الشجاع حين يقول له بعد ما اسيطر على
منطقه المخلاف السليماني وعلى ابو عريش
وهدم الحصون كان من ضمنها حصنهم مشهور في
تلك الفتره يسمى الشام
فيقول له في قصيده
مطوله ونيته بالنصر في عيش عليك هني وزادك
الله من صنعاء الى عدن
اعنيك يا بهجه الدنيا وزينتها حييتها
بالامن والاحسان وقد سمعت نبا من عندكم
عجبا ارحم مكتئبا من صوله الزمن ان قد
ملكت القصور النائفات على ابي عريش الشهير
الفردي في المدني تركتها صفصفا بالقاعه
حامده كانها في قديم العهد لم تكوني ام ست
تحوم عليها الطير وباكيه من فقدنا الفت
فيها من السكن والشامخ والشامخ المهدوم
من بعد ما قيل ان دعوت له يوفي عهود جرت
في ساله في الزمن فخان مستنكفا لم يرعى
حرمتها يا ليته لعهود الله لم يخوني وظن
جهلا يجيه شامخه هيه
الى يقول باقي الخناقه عليه حين نزلت قرن
الاسود محب الغابه والعارم
ثم يثني عليه في قصيده طويله الى ان يقول
الخيل والليل على غرار المتنبي الخيل
والليل والهجاء شهده والسيف والضيف والخطي
ماذا يساوي في باس وفي كرمه ماذا يناويه
لا ينفك ذا حزن ماذا يعاهده ثم يخالفه
[موسيقى]
بطولته تنجو من المحاني كالبر ساحته كالبر
راحته كالسحب جودته تنهل بالمزني يبكي
لهيبته والرعبته
وكل دني ويضحكون اذا لاقوها اربعه السيف
والضيف والعاني وكل سنه لازال حظك مقرونا
باربعه عز ونصر مع تايدي والمهني ودمت
بالامر محفوفا باربعه القلو والذل ودمت
بالامر
ودمت بالامر محفوفا باربعه السعد والمجد
والاقبال واليمن ولا بوليت مع الدنيا
باربعه القلو والذل والعصيان والفتاني وقد
زففت اليك عروسا بنت ساعتها القصيده طبعا
قد زففت اليك عروسا بنت ساعتها تختلف في
حلل تحسين بكرا تزف الى كفئ يكون لها ولذي
صادقه عونا على الزمن
يقول اني امدحك ولا امدح غيرك حتى لو كان
لانني من اناس ليس همه تكسب بمديح كان او
هجني امير المسلمين بلا لون عليك ولا من
ولا ثمن ويغشيك تسليمه والصلاه على خير
البريه مامون ومؤمن واله وصحبه ما غنت
مطوبقه وما لا لا براء من اليمن
ذو شعرا وقال لنا انيت بالنصري في عيش
عليك هاني ختمها بمطلعها
فالحاصل انه انه
بسبب هذا الطيب بسبب هذا
قرروا الامير محمد بن عيضه انه يكتشف
منطقه المخلاف منطقه تهامه اليمن والفعل
بدا الحصار وفي اثناء ذلك
ورد الخبر لباب العالي يرسله حملات ونشدات
سريعه جدا ورد الخبر الامير محمد بن عايض
ان هناك حملات ايضا اخرى مضافه الى منطقه
عسير ولم يكن بالامكان ان يترك منطقه عسير
ويكون في اليمن
رجعه رجعه ويقال انه حدثت انتهاكات او بعض
الاخطاء من جيشه
وسبب ذلك ان هناك ربما يكون بعض
المشط او بعض الاهالي في منطقه الحديده
وكذا ربما يكونوا قد كانوا مع العثمانيين
او عينا لهم
فهم حدثت بحسب المصادر اليمنيه انه حدثت
هناك بعض الانتهاكات التي بحق الاهالي
هناك رجاء الامير محمد بن عايض الى الى
منطقه عسير
وكان في ظنه
العثمانيين حمله رديف باشا طبعا لن يصعد
الى الى ابها الا عن طريق عقبه
باعتبار الكبرى والرئيسيه والمعدات
الثقيله اللي تاتيه منها
وكان ايضا ايضا كان يظن
وقادته كذلك يظنون انه
انه المنطقه
مبهمه مجهوله المئاتي من ليست معلومه
جغرافيه وطرقها هناك عدد من الطرق القريبه
جدا من مقره في ريده في الشقق ولكن يظن
انهم لن ياتون
مع مع رفيف باشا القائد الذي نزل في منطقه
القنفذه او القنفذه كان هناك بعض الذين
تواضعوا
مع مع رضيف باشا شخصيات معلومه معروفه
وكانتش بمثابه دليل الارشاد جغرافيا الى
الى منطقه عسير بالفعل دخلت دخل الجيش
واشار المشير هذا الرجل اشار المشير الى
لا ياتون مع شعار وانما ياتون مع منطقه
عقبه الصماء
الغربيه بسهوله شديده جدا وبالفعل وارسل
ايضا كتيبه لمشاغله الامير محمد بن عايض
في شعار وكان الامير محمد 25,000 وقاتل
يا ريت الخبر للامير محمد بن عايض انه انه
الاتراك العثمانيين او حمله رديف باشا قد
باتت مسيطره على منطقه مناطق الجنوبيه من
الشجره وصاروا هم الاتراك العثمانيين اقرب
من محمد بن عايض الامير محمد بن عايض
رجع
باعتباطيا وعبثا رجعوا ومعه هؤلاء
المقاتلين
وحدثت بينهم معارك في منطقه الصعيد
وانتهت الى انه مقاتل الامير محمد بن عايض
استطاعه
حصلتهم القوات العثمانيه وحمله رديف باشا
وعلى اثر ذلك بدل حصار
وكان هناك جمله من الحضور التاريخيه التي
ساعدت العثمانيه في الانتصار في حمله رديف
باشا الحظ الاول هذا المرشد
الحظ الثاني
مسمار
كان كل المستودع الموجود في الذخيره
مستودع الحصن او المعقل هذا كان مليء
بالذخيره يقال انه نزلت شراره على
المستودع كان فيه مئات القتل مئات
المقاتلين المدافعين عنه فانفجر المعقل
بما فيه وهذا سبب انهيار كبير في
المعنويات المقاتلين
وعلى تلذلك انسحبوا الى منطقه الحفير وهي
مطله على ريده وكان واضح
انه انه الامير محمد بن عايض يخطط على انه
تكون رائده النهائي والخط الدفاعي الاخير
وبالفعل حدثت معارك كبيره في منطقه الحفير
لمده خمسه ايام ثم انسحب الامير محمد بن
عايف الى الى ريته يقول العلامه الحفظ في
هذا الصدر
عن ريده وعن
تكوينها وليس يظن ان تغلب عن قله ولا يلوح
في الاذهان ان يظهر عدو بفتحها
فسبحان من لا يغلبه ومن فيه ومن في قدرته
ضعف المطلوب
في الاذهان ابدا
لانه ليس لهم الا طريق واحده فقط القادمه
من من الشقق الطريق ال ال ال ال الغربيه
الاتيه من البحر
مبهمه طرقها معدومه مجهوله بالكامل لا
يعرفها الا الرجل
بانزال المعدات الثقيله في ثغر الشقيق
وبالفعل وسحب هذه المعدات عن طريق وادي
مرابعه وبالفعل
حين وصلت هذه
سحبت هذه المدافع عن طريق الوادي حتى
يقال حتى من ضمن الاحداث التي حصلت انه
كان في تلك الايام في اثناء القتال او في
اثناء حصار ايضا وكانت في الامطار غزيره
جدا والضباب كثيفا للغايه فكان الذين في
المعاقل من المدافعين لا يرون شيئا لا
يرون شيئا وهذا ما جعل محمد رديف باشا
يستطيع بسهوله ان ينصب مدافعه في الجبهه
الغربيه
ولذلك
نجح في نصب مدافعه وبتت ريده بين شقيقه
بين قوات
العثمانيه القادمه من الشرق ومن الحفير
والقوات الاخرى القادمه من وادي ربه
وبالفعل بدات الحصون
وكانت المعاقل كبيره جدا
وعلى اثر ذلك
انهارت المعنويات بدرجه كبيره جدا وامن
الجميع انه سقوطها وتحتميه
ولكن
بحسب المصادر الموجوده انه استخرج فرمان
سلطاني يقضي بالعفو عن الامير محمد بن
عايض مقابله التسليم
واستسلم لاحمد مختار باشا
وهو احد الجنرالات الموجودين باشا
وصل رديف باشا الى ريده وكان متشددا
متعمدا
في ليله من احدى الليالي بعد التسليم
حسب الروايات
انه اقدم على قتل 35 من الاشرار طبعا
الاشرار
عاطف باشا
يعني حوالي 400 شخص
انه في اثناء الحديث الامير سعد بن عايض
اخو الامير
لكن مثل هذه المعلومات ربما تصح او ربما
لا تثبت لا يوجد دليل القاطع صحيح انه
مشيره اليها او اشير لانه ذرى ما لحق
بمحمد باشا في المذكرات العثمانيين لكن من
يوضح ذلك
على اسم ذلك يقتل الامير محمد بن عايض
هو
رديف باشا ويقتل 35 رجلا من كبار قياداته
ثم يؤشر 600 رجل كان من علمها احمد بن عبد
الخالق الحفظ
ويرسلون الى
السلطنه العثمانيه
احمد العلامه احمد بن عبد الخالق الحظي
نفي الى منطقه ينانيه في البانيا
كانت تابعه للدوله العثمانيه
وبقيت بالمئات هناك كثير منهم توفي في
المنفى
وبعضهم عاد كان من ضمنهم احمد بن عبد
الخالق الحمضي الذي ارسل قصائد كان يرسل
قصائد من ضمنها حكايه ومشتاق لدارا واهله
واخوانه
يشكي غربته الى الله سبحانه وتعالى ويطلبه
الفرج
نبي الله
ويا مخرج الصديق يوسف
النيران بردا جميعها على جسمي ابراهيم
فنحن لك الداعون في كل ساعه ونحن لك
الراجون في دفع
ومن تلك الواقعه تسقط اماره الامير محمد
بن علي وتدخل منطقه عسير في في
في فتره زمنيه مظلمه
علميا وثقافيه وامنيا واجتماعيا وحدث
التغيرات كبيره في خلال
47 سنه
الوجود العثماني 47 سنه
جدا لكن هذه الثورات زادت الوضع سوءا
لانها لم تنجح لم تفلح في نزع الوجود
العثماني
فادت هذه ال ال ال ال
الفتره كانت فتره مظلمه يعني حتى علميه
حتى ثقافيه اجتماعيا امنيا
حدث التغيرات كثيره جدا
بعكس الفتره السابقه التي بدات منذ ايام
الامير محمد بن عامر
الان تقريبا يكاد ينقطع في الفتره الوجود
العثماني ولذلك مثلا سنجد في
فتره الامير سعيد ومسلط هو الامير علي
ستكون عشير في تلك المنطقه في تلك الفتره
وفتره الاميره مرعي للكثير من العلماء
باشكال مختلفه من التوجهات والمشاكل سنجد
مثلا العلامه مسفر بن جعيلان الدوسري
الحمد لله عالم فقيه حنبلي ينزل في وادي
العرين بمدينه ابها ويصبحوا نديه حلقه
علميه مشهوره
سياتي احمد بن ادريس من المغرب
ويستقر في صبيا ويقوم الامير علي بن جثثل
بكفايته الماليه
سياتي احمد ابن احمد النعمي من علماء صعده
ويستقر ايضا في ابها عبد الله بن سرور
الحمداني وهو ايضا من علماء نجران سيستقر
في مدينه ابها هناك ايضا محمد بن يحيى
الضمدي من اهل اهالي ضمه الشافعي يستقر
ايضا في وادي الصليل كل هؤلاء صارت منطقه
عسير لماذا لانها كانت خارج السيطره
العثمانيه
وكانوا من مشاري مختلفه ولذلك مثلا مناظره
مشهوره في حضره الامير علي بين احمد بن
ادريس العلامه المتصور وبين العلماء
السلفي
وهم ثلاثه علماء مصر القديمه
الاصول التي تقوم عليها الشريعه الاسلاميه
عن كثير من المسائل التي كانت تمثل شواغل
ذلك العصر انا الموقف من دعوه الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الوهاب
كانت مناظره في غايه الاهميه وتعكس وتعكس
ايضا
امم تعكس ايضا حتى وعيا سياسيه من الامير
علي بن مجفل بانه كان يستوعب الجميع رغم
انه كان مشهور بالديانه في نفس الوقت
وكانت علماء وكان علماء عشير في تلك
الفتره يعني على اشكال مختلفه حتى في حتى
في وين كان يسود عليهم طبعا الوعي السلفي
لكن كان في ذلك الوقت
يعني
ياخذون الوعي السلفي
بكل حمولاتي وهناك اناس متخففين لحد ما
يستوعبون وكذا
في فتره الامير علي الامير محمد بن عايض
ومن قبلهم حتى كانت هناك
قصائد شعريه نثريه تاليف تاريخ في الانشاد
في العقيده هناك كتابه مشهور اسمه تحقيق
التجريد شرح كتاب التوحيد في مجلدين
للعلامه هادي محمد العريفي هناك تفسير
القران الكريم للعلامه احمد بن عبد الخالق
الحصري وكان هناك همم
العلامه محمد بن يحيى النعمي الا في كتابا
في الفقه الشافعي وهنا العديد من الشمال
الحياه العلميه الجيده
تدخل عشير في في نفق مظلم الان و يصبح
الوجود العثماني يستمر 47 سنه
تقوم ثورات عديده ثورات اشهرها ثوره
الامير ناصر بن نايف
ولم تنجح توفي سنه 1299 ثم تقوم ثوره
يقوده الامير علي بن محمد
لمده حوالي 25 سنه
1299 او في اخر في ذي الحجه من سنه 1298
حتى تقريبا وفاته في سنه 1226 حاصر ابها
قطع خطوط الامدادات العثمانيه حصر الوجود
العثماني فقط في ثكناته العسكريه خرجت
كثير من مناطق عسير خارجه عن الوجود
العثماني لكن ماذا سبب ذلك سبب ذلك وجودا
امنيا ضعيفا
هناك تنازع
بين العهدت في تلك الفتره الحارقه
تضخمت القبيله بشكل كبير جدا وهذا وهذا
ملاحظ في تلك الفتره
قبليه
لانه السلطه المحليه التي كانت موجوده
وكانت تستطيع ان تلم الجميع
القبليين اصبحوا اكثر حضوره من ذي قبل لان
الناس لم يكونوا يؤمنون اصلا بالوجود
العثماني كوجود شرعي
على مكوناتهم اصبح الزعيم القبلي له دور
كبير الوجود العثماني نفسه ضخم دور
القبيله ودور شيخها باعتبار ان السيطره
على شيخ القبيله يسيطر على القبيله تغيرت
كثير من من التركيبه الاجتماعيه التي كانت
موجوده في تلك الفتره
توفي الامير علي بن محمد بن عايض مسموما
بصح الروايات سنه 1326
[موسيقى]
المشهوره في صبيا
ووقتها كان الامير علي بن محمد وهو لا
يعلم بانه اضعف الوجود العثماني في كل
مناطق عشيره المخلف سليمان
وخرج تقريبا منطقه المخلاف السليماني كانت
خارجه تماما تقريبا الا في مدينه جيزان
فقط الثغره البحري
السيد محمد بن علي الادريسي ويستمد
ايطاليا
من خلال التعاون معها وكان رجل في بدايه
حياته وكان له نفوذ رمزي كبير جدا ورثه عن
اخلافه
الاعلى احمد بن ادريس الذي قدم من المغرب
صاحب الطريقه الاحمديه المشهوره في التصوف
مش هيقول له حضور كبير وسيحاصر او سيقوم
بمشروع سياسي
يحاولوا من خلاله
تصفيه الوجود العثماني في في منطقه عسير
فل كامل والمخلف السليماني
وهذا الوقت كانت
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه
في هذا التحديد في اثناء ثورات الامير علي
بن محمد يبدا مشروع الملك المؤسسه الثانيه
عسير في تلك الفتره
في اهلي ذكر الامام فيصل بن تركي كانت
علاقه متميزه جدا
لكن في بعد وفاه الامام فيصل بن تركي
دخل كان الامام الشرعي والامام عبد الله
بن فيصل حدث نجاح بين الامام عبد الله بن
فيصل
وبين الامام سعود واتجاه الامام سعود الى
الامير محمد
الامير
الرسائل رسم مراسلات من الامام عبدالله
بن فيصل تطالبه بعدم التدخل وهذا الذي
فعله كان الامير محمد حريص على رقم الصدر
بين الاخوين لكن في نهايه المطاف التجاء
الامير الامام
يتمدد الدوله السعوديه الثانيه الى مناطق
جنوب غرب الجزيره العربيه كانت خريطتها
السياسيه اقل لحد الدمام من الدوله
السعوديه الاولى لكنها كانت قويه جدا في
وسط الجزيره العربيه
همم مؤسس الملك عبد العزيز
حين قام الملك عبد العزيز بمرور
الوحداوي كان الوقت على الامير علي بن
محمد كان يثور يقدم ثوره يحاصر ابها في
حوالي 25000 مقاتل لكن العثمانيين كانوا
قد بنو كثير من المعاقين المهمه جدا ولا
سالت موجوده القلاع العثمانيه الموجوده في
منطقه عسير في مدينه ابها تحديدا ولذلك من
الصعب جدا اقتحام المدينه وفشل الحصار
وبعدها توفي الامير علي بن محمد مصمومه في
بلده الحرمله تسمى وهي موقع حصين جدا جدا
جدا كان اراد من خلاله ان يكون في من انت
من وجود العثمان
خلال ذلك الملك عبد العزيز كان يقوم
بمشروعيه الوحده
[موسيقى]
ويتمكن
بنجاحات باهره جدا في السيطره على منطقه
نجد ثم يمد نفوذه دائما هذه
الحركه التاريخيه السعوديه انها كانت حين
تخرج من منطقه نجد تذهب مباشره
وجغرافيا ولذلك الملك عبد العزيز يسيطر في
سنه 1913 على منطقه الاحساء ويطرد او
يسترد العشاء من الوجود العثماني
ويصبح يطلع على الخليج ويصبح اقوى قوه
سياسيه موجوده على الخليج العربي
وهذا ما جعل
بريطانيا ترضخ ينتقد معه اتفاقيه في سنه
1915 لذلك بعد ذلك الملك عبد العزيز و بعد
ان حصلته حصر اماره ال الرشيد في حائل
يبدا صوت همم
في هذه الاثناء كانت الحرب العالميه
الاولى
الحرب العالميه الاولى على وشك او او بدات
كامل
الادريسي وقتا كان قد اصطفى مع الايطاليين
الانجليزي لاحقا
الشريف حسين في اثناء الحرب العالميه
الاولى كانوا يعتبر
رجل بريطانيا الاول في الجزيره العربيه
سنه 1916
الامير حسن الذي او نائب المتصرف
العثمانيين اوجدوا السياسه بعد ثورات
الامير علي بن محمد بن عايض وهي احتواء
افراد هذه الاسره
اسره العائله السبب في ذلك رغبه في
الامساك في المجتمع والسبب في ذلك للتفرغ
لجبهات القتال خاصه مع قيام التكتلات
الحرب العالميه
فكان من ضمن هذا التعيين الامير حسن بن
عايض معاويه
الامير حسن
لكن مع ذلك بسبب ضغط الظروف
من حازم او او او له علاقه وطيده
بالقوه الامبرياليه مثل ايطاليا وبريطانيا
وعلى اثر ذلك
في خلال هذه الفترات الملك عبد العزيز
يتقدم غربا
ويسيطر على منطقه
تربه او تحدث بينه بينه وبين الشريف حسين
واقع التربه المشهوره سنه 1337 والتي على
اثرها
الملك عبد العزيز والرجل الاول في في في
المنطقه في جزيره العربيه
خلال هذه الفتره
في سنه 1337 في نفس العام في نفس العام
توقع اتفاقيه من دروس
وتعلن الدوله العثمانيه انسحاب من اراضي
جزيره في العالم
وفي مقتضى هذه الاتفاقيه
يستقل الامير حسن بن علي في منطقه عسير
الامير حسن بن علي
وهذا هو العقد الاجتماعي الذي قامت عليه
هذه الاماره الامير حسن بن علي الان يتخلى
الاجتماعيه
في مرحله صعبه جدا كان من ضمنها مثلا انه
القبائل تضخمت بدرجه كبيره خلال تقريبا
الادريسي يصبح له علاقات متينه
العديد من الاهالي والعديد من المؤثرين في
المجتمع
بوجود
الاتفاقيه التي عقدتها مع الحلفاء
وتعلن هزيمتها في في عام 1918
1918 تقريبا 1337 وعلى اثر ذلك
ياتي الادريسي ويحاول السيطره على منطقه
حشيش
الامير حسن طبعا وقع اتفاقيه لانه كان
ضعيف
بمقتضى هيكون نائبا في عسير للسيد
الادريسي مقابل ان يحصل على لانه كانت
الخزينه يعني
لكن في تلك الاثنان كان في هناك جناح في
اماره الامير حسن يرى انه التفاوض مع شريف
فهذا الجناح غلط في النهايه ووقع اتفاقيه
مع الشريف حسين
كان من ضمن البنود الاتفاقيه التي وقعها
الامير حسن مع السيد الادريسي انه لابد من
تسليم الذخيره العثمانيه وكان العثمانيون
قد تركه العديد من الذخائر العسكريه
والحربيه في في ابها يعني كما يقال وهذا
فعلوه مع الامام يحيى حميد الدين في اليمن
مع العثمانيين في الحرب العالميه الاولى
ماذا ذلك
الادريسي اراد ان يسيطر على منطقه عسير
ويحاكم الامير حسن بمقتضى هذه الاتفاقين
ولابد من تسليم الدخيره
على كامل اليمن
ترسل الجيوش واضح انه الكفه كانت في صالح
السيد الادريسي تصعد الجيوش من البطحاء
في جنوب ابها ثم يصعد الجيش الثاني من
عقبه الصمه من شمال غرب ابها واضح انه كان
الوقت نقطه التقاء الجيشي مدينه ابها
المفارقه انه الامير حسن انتصر انتصارا
كبيرا على الجيش الذي قدم من الصدمه ثم
شير الجيش الاخر شير المنتصرون
[موسيقى]
رغم ان بريطانيا امدته بعديه من المقاتلين
الصوماليين من القرن الافريقي لكنه
وخرج الامير حسن منتصره من هذه المعركه
باقل الخشاير وبمفارقه
وطبعا لها تعليلات كثيره اجتماعيه ربما
انه الاهالي او بعض الاهالي الذين كانوا
مع السيد الادريسي لم يروا ولم يستشروا
ابدا ان يرفعوا بنادقهم الامير حسن
ومقاتله
باعتبار انه مجتمعا واحد يعني في النهايه
باعتباره انهم مجتمع واحد يعني صعب جدا
الحاصل انه
وقت الامير الملك عبد العزيز سيطر على
بيشه
كان مسيطر على بيشه تعتبر البوابه الشرقيه
الشماليه
خلال ذلك الامير حسن بدا يعدوا الجيوش
لنزول الى صبيا
الاستئصال النفوذ السيد الادريسي
همم
حقيقي في الامام يحيى حميد الدين في تهامه
اليمن
وعبير عشير ينتصر عليه في الشراره ويبدا
يعد جيوشه
فاستنجد بالملك عبد العزيز
وكانت علاقته الملك عبد العزيز
[موسيقى]
ربما تكون غير موفقه يعني اقدم على تصفيه
حساباته مع العيان او الاهالي الذين وقفوا
مع السيد الادريسي في اثناء الشراعي
فقام بي عمليات عسكريه وقرات عسكريه تجاه
عدد من
من
الجهات والمناطق
وهذا ما ادى الى الى تفاقم الوضع في داخل
منطقه عسير
وهذا هو السبب الذي الذي
ظهرت فيه العديد من المصادر التاريخيه
الحديثه التي تقول بانه انه الامير حسن
كان ظالم
كان هناك نوع من الشطب في في سياسته اتجاه
الجامعه هو نظر الى هؤلاء الناس
بانهم وقفوا مع السيد ادريس فلم يرى لابد
راى انه لابد من تنكيلهم ومحاسبتهما
وعلى اثر ذلك على اثر ذلك
بعث الرساله الى الملك عبد العزيز يستنجده
وفي نفس الوقت كانه كان يطالب او يؤشر او
يذكر انه انه الامير حسن قد جمع بين
الاختين جماعه بين الاختين
والغرض من ذلك هو تحريض
المقاتلين الذين كانوا
مع الملك عبد العزيز الاخوان السعوديين
الذين كانوا متبنين
كانوا يعتبرون متمنين تبنين كامل الا دعوه
الشيخ محمد عبد الوهاب على اثر ذلك
بسبب هذه
التحرير طبعا وهذا غير صحيح واقعيه الامير
حسن بن عايض تزوج امراه ثم ماتت ثم تزوج
اختها
بس لكن السيد الرئيس
الاخير
في سنه 1338
الامير حسن ارسل رساله
بليغ جدا الى الامير عبد العزيز بن مساعد
وكانت شفافه للغايه وتبين حجم العلاقه
وانه المصادر التاريخيه التي تبين انه
العلاقه غير جيده
كان من ضمن الكلام الذي يقوله
وتعلمون بارك الله فيكم ما بين الحمولاتين
وال سعود
ونبين لكم باننا يا رجال عسير نؤمن بالله
ورسوله وباليوم الاخر
ومن قال غير هذا القول فقد افترى على الله
واهله وفقد افترى على الله ولابد ان يظهر
الله الصدق واهله ويكبت السوء واهله
ويريد ان يطمئن الملك عبد العزيز انه من
الناحيه او الامير عبد العزيز بن مساعد
قائد الجيش
كما ذكر في الرساله ايضا مثاليبه على
السيد الادريسي
بما يوحي بان الامير
كانت هذه نقطه مفصليه ولا مساومه
من النصوص والمصادر لم يكن لديه اشكال في
الانضمام في كان في الملك عبد العزيز لم
يكن له لكن كان هناك جناح متشدد في
اماراتي في اماراته
معارض لهذه الفكره ولا الامير حسن بن عايض
كان يؤثر السلامه
فهذا الجناح هو الذي
من من مقاومه جيش الملك عبد العزيز
بين الطرفين معركه مشهوره تسمى معركه حجله
وهي معركه كانت فيها المساله حاضره من
الطرفين
وكان كان كان المهاجمون شجعان وكان
المدافعون ايضا شجاعه
وانتصرت في نهايه المطاف الوحده الوطنيه
انتصر في نهايه المطاف مشروع الملك عبد
العزيز
في في في في
راي في مشروع الملك عبد العزيز الذي هو
المصرح الوطني
مفاوضات مباشره بين الامير حسن الامير عبد
العزيز بن مساعد
ويتفق رجلان على ان يذهب الامير حسن الى
الملك عبد العزيز وبالفعل ذهب الامير حسن
الى الملك عبد العزيز
واعطي الاهالي الامان
وبدخلت ابها في في كان في الملك عبد
العزيز وعلى اثر ذلك حددت الحدود وقتها
حدود طبعا
بحسب مرحله التاريخيه مع السيد الادريسي
السيد الادريسي
بقيت معه جزء من منطقه تهامه عسير خاصه
تهامه الجنوبيه ما يتعلق برجال الماء تلك
المنطقه
ومنطقه قنا والبحر وكذا في حين انه الملك
عبد العزيز سيطر على منطقه علي عشيره
التهاميه الشماليه فضلا عن الشرح محايل
وبارك
الملك عبد العزيز في بلاد عسير وعلى اثر
ذلك ايضا لا تنتهي المساله الا هذا الحد
لانه السيد الادريسي يتوفى بعدها بثلاثه
اعوام سنه 1341
وتدخل الاماره الادريسيه في صراع او في
حرب اهليه تنافس السلطه
الادريسي وبين الامام الذي خلف والده
الامام علي
وعمه ايضا الامام الحسن
ويصبح هناك صراع مريض جدا ويضعف منطقه
المخلاف السليماني الى درجه ان الامام
يحيى حميد الدين
يسيطر على منطقه تهامه اليمن التي كانت
خاضعه للنفوذ السيد الادريسي يسيطر على كل
هذه المناطق حتى تقريبا ميتي او حرف
الادريسي نفسه
الادريسي والملك عبد العزيز يعقد اتفاقيه
في سنه 1345
1925 تسمى اتفاقيه مكه المكرمه
والتي هي هي مضمونها الحمايه الملك عبد
العزيز في هذه الاماره حمايت
[موسيقى]
كان مندوب الاول واحد اسمه صالح بن عبد
الواحد ثم عبد الله الخثلان
ثم تقريبا
ربما يكون
حمد الشويعر يمكن لقاء
الامير حسن مع الملك عبد العزيز
الملك عبد العزيز طبعا المعروف
والحوادث في ذلك طافحه كثيره من اهم مثلا
حادثه جبل العروس
350 تبين سماحه الملك عبد العزيز
350 اعتدت القوات اليمنيه على جبل العرض
وسيطرت عليه بالكامل الملك عبد العزيز
ارسل رساله للامام يحيى حميد الدين فيها
نوع من
الاشتياق وفي انواع من التشاؤل عن هذا
الفعل
حميد الدين بعثها برساله اخويه الملك عبد
العزيز يقول فيها انه هذا الامر
نحن نحكمك الملك عبد العزيز في هذه
المساله الملك عبد العزيز
اعطي جبل العروس لكن حتى وان كان الملك
عبد العزيز متسامحه للغايه لانه كان لم
ياتي يعني في القرن العشرين في المنطقه
العربيه شخص مثلا يعني بقدر ما انواع
الامام يحيى حميد الدين
لانه كان ذلك الجبل بمثابه الحج
بانه ذلك الجبل من هو شمالا
ايضا سياسيا ودهان سياسيين
انه كان دور الدوله السعوديه الاولى مهما
في همم
اصول الحجاز الذي الذي الذي
قادت بعد بعد الذين هزموا في معركه حجره
طلائع القوات
لقوات السعوديه التي تحاصر الرغامه وصارت
اكثر اكثر المؤن تصل من منطقه عسير التي
في الدوله في عهد الملك عبد العزيز الذين
حاصروا الرغامه كان اكثر كان اكثرهم من
الذين قاتلوا مع الامير حسن بن علي ناس
كانوا كانوا يريدون يا اخي عبد الرحمن
كانوا بحاجه الى مشروع سياسي جامع
وهذا لم يكن يتحول الملك عبد العزيز شخصيه
استثنائيه لنتذكر ان ينظر دائما الملك عبد
العزيز في اشياء عسكريه
وهذا وهذا انا اعتبره خطا كبير جدا وليس
فقط في سياقه عسكريه الملك عبد العزيز رجل
تحديثي من الطراز الاول لم يماشش الدوله
الا الملك عبد العزيز جميع الوزارات جميع
الوزارات اسست وحدثت في عهد الملك عبد
العزيز
الذي كان تعليما ااه
اهليه تمت مؤسسته في عهد الملك عبد العزيز
حتى التعليم الجامعي كليه الشريعه في في
في في مكه المكرمه كان في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الطرق شبكه الطرق البريه شبكه الطرق النقل
الجوي حتى الطائرات الشرطه وزاره الدفاع
كلها
مؤسسه لذلك الملك عبد العزيز كان يفوق 10
وكان ينظر للغيم من ستر الرقيب بلا شك
وكان وكان
في بعض الاحيان
يقف المراه من عده مشاكل
التفسير من من يصنع منه هل الظرف هو الذي
يصنع البطل
او البطل هو الذي يصنع الظرف
لانه علاقه جدليه هل الظرف هو الذي يصنع
البطل كما يقول الماركسيون
امن البطل لديه صفات فطريه خارقه يستطيع
ان يجير ظروف كما تقول فلسفه واحد كارلين
بسكتلندي واحد من اقطاب الفكر
الملك عبد العزيز
بقدر ما ان الظروف ظروف المجتمع الحافه به
عمقه تاريخي غربته في الكويت ااا
معرفته التاريخيه واضح انه من خلال سير
معارك كانه كان ينظر للتاريخ ايضا كما
ينظر المستقبل
الى الى الى
قيادته وصفاته الفطريه هي النتيجه جعلته
هذه الظروف يجير هذه الظروف وايضا الظروف
نفسها ايضا ساعدت في تشكيل يعني شخصيه بطل
مثل شخصيه الملك عبد العزيز نتذكر انه انه
المجتمع كان فيه حاجه ماسه جدا سواء في
الحجاز او في الاحساء او في شمال المملكه
او في جنوب المملكه الى شخصيه الملك عبد
العزيز
يعني كل من نظر الى شخصيه الملك عبد
العزيز وما فعله كان يشعر انه الظرف
الظروف كبيره جدا لا يمكن تجاوزها
ويتذكر انه انه خطوره وجود الملك عبد
العزيز في تلك المرحله انه خطوره مع بدايه
نشوء النظام الدولي والتنافس العثماني
البريطاني المرير على الجزيره العربيه مع
ذلك تخيل وان الملك عبد العزيز نجح نجاح
يعني لكم ان تتخيلوا
انه لم يصادق الاتراك
وفي نفس الوقت
لم يعادل انجليزي
وحين صادق مثلا او كانت علاقات المتينه مع
الانجليز
الا انه في اثناء الحرب العالميه الاولى
لم يطلق طلقه واحده على العثماني
يعني كان الملك عبد العزيز يجيد يجيد وضع
كيانه سياسي ومشروعه السياسي ونفوده
السياسي في الموقف الصحيح
وكان ملحمه
كل هذه المسائل الملك عبد العزيز حتى في
في مساله ما يخص
توحيد المناطق جنوب المملكه
يعني في في حين فرض الحمايه والاتفاقيه في
سنه 1345 اوعى الامام يحيى حميد
[موسيقى]
الحدود مع ذلك
لم يستمر الوضع طويلا
الاداره اداره الريشي
لكن اداره ضعيفه وهشاشه جدا
الامام يحيى حميد الدنيا تطلع الى مد
نفوذه باي شكل وينظر الى الادريسي على انه
مغتصب منطقه
ينظر اليها منطقه يمنيه تم اختصابه
وعلى اثر ذلك تقوم لانه الملك عبد العزيز
والمطالبه الملك عبد العزيز بالحدود من
يطلع على الكتاب الاخضر
الملك عبد العزيز وكيف انه الملك عبد
العزيز حتى في رسائله اللي كانت تحمل ودا
كبير الامام يحيى حميد يحاول يقدر الامكان
التسويه في حين انه كان هناك مماطله كبيره
جدا من الجانب اليمن كانت واضحه
وكان الملك عبد العزيز في كثير من اللحظات
كان متشامحه للغايه حتى اذا جاء تقريبا
عام 13
51 يتمرد الحسن الادريسي
باعاج من الامام يحيى حميد الدين
وبيتفاق مع حزب الاحرار الهاشمي
ترسل حمله عسكريه يقوده الامير عبد العزيز
بن مساعد
ويفرض الملك عبد العزيز سيطرته
ويعلن تاسيس المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
اثر ذلك او توحيد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في تلك المنافسات
ويرسل الامام يحيى حميد الدين حسن
الادريسي المتمرد يذهب الى منطقه شهامه
اليمن
ويستقر في سبيل
يرسل الامام يحيى حميد الدين الملك عبد
العزيز يقول انه الحسن الادريسي ومن معه
في
ضيافتي الملك عبد العزيز
السياسي لانه هو احدث وهذا بمقتضى اتفاقيه
العرب
في في احد بنودها عام 1350 تقريبا انه
لابد من تسليم اي محدث سياسي والرجل محدث
في رفض الامام يحيى حميد الدين وقال بل
بالعكس نحن نطالب الملك عبد العزيز
فيرسل الملك عبد العزيز
[موسيقى]
انا سماحه مطلق
ثم حين حين تقوم الحرب السعوديه اليمنيه
وسيطر الملك فيصل على الحديده
وتنسحب القوات اليمنيه من نجران وترسم
الحدود في سنه 1353 كان الملك عبد العزيز
مطالب واحده مطالبه واضحه وواحده يعني منذ
تقريبا من فتره طويله جدا في اثناء
المفاوضات مساله الحدود نجران
عوده الحسن الادريسي
[موسيقى]
حين وقعت اتفاقيه الطائف سنه 1353
بالمخصصات من الملك عبد العزيز والملك عبد
العزيز
ارقام اكثرهم تقريبا في مدينه الطائف فهمم
وعلى اثر ذلك تقريبا انتهت مشكله الحدود
السياسيه
سنه 1983
[موسيقى]
وعلى فكره هذا تمثيليه
الله يحفظكم الله يسعدكم ويبارك فيكم شكرا
لك شكرا لكم
الحربي في اعداد الحلقه وهاب موسى في
التصوير
الهندسه الصوتيه
وانس الخليل في تحرير في هذه الحلقه في
اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نوره
السبيعي عبد المجيد العباس في التلوين هذا
فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج بحب مدينه
الرياض الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]